Wie viel glaubt ihr, dass dieses vorwärtsgewordene Umfeld wert ist? Wartet nur einen Moment bevor ihr antwortet. Schaut, wie Windows mit Miami Vice Lotus 123 integriert. Jetzt können wir diesen Ferrari und den Windows Write verpasten. Wie viel glaubt ihr, dass Microsoft Windows wert ist? Wartet und hört auf, Windows Write und Windows Paint und sie werden hören, was du noch mehr hast. 1.000? Es ist ein unglaublicher Wert, aber es ist wahr, es sind Windows für Microsoft, bestellen heute!
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nr. 101 und damit die erste Ausgabe der dritten Saison von Chaosradio, die jetzt beginnt, die sich jetzt noch mal kurz vor den Weihnachtsfeiertagen auch die eine oder andere Sendung noch gönnt. Ganz unerwartet, richtig loslegen werde ich dann allerdings erst 2009. Aber man soll die Podcasts so aufnehmen, wie sich die Gelegenheiten bieten. Und heute bin ich ins schöne München gefahren, mal wieder. Und ja, begrüße alte Bekannte von Chaosradio Express, alte Bekannte auch für viele Podcast-Hörer sowieso, nämlich den Dominik und den Martin. Hallo. Hoi hoi. Und wir haben ja schon mal gepodcastet, ganz fleißig über den Macintosh, über die Anwendungsentwicklung in CAE Nummer 70, wo wir ausführlich mal zusammengetragen haben, was denn eigentlich so alles dazugehört, auf den Macintosh Anwendungen zu entwickeln, sind so durch die Frameworks gestiefelt und sonstige Untiefen von Mac OS X. Ja, ich finde eigentlich eine ganz gut gelungene Übersicht. Und wer sozusagen diese Sendung gehört hat, der hat auch schon mal das richtige Rüstzug für die heutige Sendung. Denn heute soll es gehen um das iPhone. Das ist natürlich ein heißes Eisen. Denn wie immer, wenn Apple mal wieder so ein neues Produkt rausbringt, teilt sich die Welt offensichtlich genau in zwei Lager. Die Leute, die dieses Gelühen verehren und die Leute, die sich denken, das wäre ja überhaupt nicht wahr. Das Schlimmste und der Feuerregen vom Himmel und so. Wie auch immer man dazu steht, lässt sich nicht leugnen, dass das iPhone eine beträchtliche Wirkung gezeigt hat. Nicht nur, was so jetzt die Kraft am Markt betrifft und wie viele Leute sich das mittlerweile zugelegt haben oder auch nicht. Sondern schlicht und ergreifend, dass es Apple mal wieder gelungen zu sein scheint, ein paar Paradigmenwechsel anzustoßen, die vorher einfach nicht so da waren. Also von, wie wäre es denn mal, wenn man ein Telefon auch einfach bedienen kann? Sag ich mal. Aber wo es, glaube ich, noch sehr viel wichtiger ist, und was für mich auch eigentlich so ein bisschen Grund und Anlass ist, hier jetzt diesen Podcast drüber zu machen. Dass sie auch eben begonnen haben zu sagen, so ein Gerät muss man fundamental anders benutzen als einen normalen Computer. Denn es ist keiner. Es ist zwar technisch sicherlich ein Computer und das gilt für das iPhone mehr als für andere, weil sie ja dort auch mehr oder weniger dasselbe OS einsetzen. Darüber wollen wir ja auch gleich sprechen. Nur sagen sie einfach, die Bedienung ist anders. Sie haben halt alles weggelassen, was so PDAs in den letzten Jahren so für normal gehalten haben. Tastaturen, eine Unzahl von speziellen Knöpfen. Ein paar spezielle Knöpfe sind natürlich nach wie vor dran. Und auch so Stifte und so eine Geschichte. Ich weiß noch ganz gut, ich habe vor einem Jahr oder so auf dem Niedungstag, hatte ich so ein Modell von OpenMoco, von diesem Frihrerner mal in der Hand. Und ich hatte ja auch mit dem Harald Welte schon vorher mal ein Podcast gemacht. Und das war ja alles sehr interessant, welche technische Initiative an der Stelle ergriffen wurde, um überhaupt so ein Gerät mal mit Open Source Software betreiben zu können, was ja nicht ganz einfach ist, insbesondere in diesem GSM-Markt. Hab dann aber relativ enttäuscht feststellen müssen, dass eigentlich sich in der Oberfläche erstmal herzlich wenig getan hat im Vergleich zu dem, wie Entwickler eben an eine Desktop rangehen. Das heißt, da hatte man so kleine Scrollbars und alles war so tiny tiny. Und dann musste man eben so einen Stift nehmen. Und ich dachte mir so, das kann zwar jetzt wohl nicht sein. Dann kam Apple wenig später raus mit dem iPhone und meinte, nehmt doch einfach euren Finger. Ja, vielleicht sollten wir mal für die Leute, die jetzt noch kein iPhone haben, kurz mal zusammentragen, was eigentlich das iPhone so ausmacht. Und was ist eigentlich drin in der Büchse? Was macht denn das iPhone technisch aus? Will sich da mal einer zu äußern von euch?
Ne, wir sagen nichts.
Wir sagen nichts.
Wir sagen nichts. Ne, nichts von unserem Anwalt. Ja, ich denke, eine Sache, die auf jeden Fall den meisten Leuten sofort ins Gesicht springt, wenn sie das Ding zum ersten Mal sehen, ist halt der Touchscreen, der Kapazitive, der halt wirklich was Neues war, denke ich, so als das iPhone zum ersten Mal kam. Dass man da wirklich über diese Glasfläche drüber fahren kann, ohne jetzt groß Energie aufzuwenden sozusagen und damit interagieren kann. Das macht das Gerät mein Ansicht nach schon in weiten Teilen aus.
Ich finde auch, auch bis jetzt noch wirklich dieses, ich muss nicht irgendwie Druck betätigen, damit da irgendwas meinen Klick wirklich bemerkt, sondern ich kann da ganz locker drüber fahren und ich habe auch keine Ermüdungserscheinungen. Ich habe jetzt auch schon bei entsprechenden Nokia-Telefonen, die jetzt auch schon mehr mit Touch und ähnliche Bedienkonzepte versuchen, einfließen zu lassen, die haben aber eben nicht diese Art von Display, sondern eine, wo man irgendwas mit mechanischem Druck auslösen muss. Und da kannst du halt weder draggen noch scrollen, ohne dass du irgendwie den Finger brichst. Das ist echt nicht mehr verheiratlich.
Warum geht das so und was macht den Bildschirm so aus, dass man das machen kann? Was ist da anders?
Ja, da ist schon ein ganz feines Metallgitter drin und da wird dann der Widerstand gemessen, wenn du den Finger drauf hältst und dementsprechend weist dann, wo der Finger ist.
Das Metallgitter, wo befindet sich das? Im Glas?
Im Glas, ja, soweit ich weiß zumindest. Ich kann mir jetzt natürlich absolut einen Unsinn erzählen gerade, aber ich dachte, da wäre wirklich so eine feine Struktur eingewoben ins Glas.
Das heißt, das ist noch über dem Bildschirm? Aber dann müsste man das doch auch sehen oder ist das so fein, dass man das nicht sieht?
Das ist wohl so fein, dass man es nicht sieht.
Okay. Das heißt, das Ganze geht quasi über, ja, so wie auch diese Softbuttons, die man so kennt, so aus dem, wie man sich ins Wohnzimmer zur Steuerung von Lampen und so weiter steuern kann. Also allein sozusagen die elektrische Leitung.
Genau. Und der Vorteil von so einer Lösung ist natürlich auch, dass du mehrere Finger gleichzeitig erkennen kannst. Wenn du halt siehst, hier ist der Widerstand irgendwie größer oder kleiner, kleiner wahrscheinlich, und da ist er kleiner und hier ist er kleiner, dann weißt du, oh, da sind drei Finger, die kann man schön trecken, da passiert irgendwas gerade.
Es geht auch erstaunlich gut. Also bis zu fünf Finger sind da durchaus am Start.
Ja gut, also irgendwann geht dir der Platz dann auf dem Display aus, je nachdem wie groß deine Finger sind. Aber ja, das funktioniert gut.
Die Technik selber hat da keine Grenzen sozusagen. Also so viel Platz, das kann man auch erkennen.
Ja, tendenziell, tendenziell.
Mehr als fünf macht wahrscheinlich nicht Sinn.
Macht wenig Sinn, aber es funktioniert auch nicht mehr richtig so gut.
Ja, man will ja nicht dann auch noch so mit dem großen C.
Daraus hat er dann irgendwie einen Halter, dass man das beziehen kann.
Weiß der Geier, weiß der Geier. So, und ein Knöppen, ist auch noch was dran?
Ja, ein bisschen. Den ich regelmäßig falsch bedient habe das erste halbe Jahr, wo ich das Telefon benutzt habe.
Wie kann man ein Knopf falsch bedienen?
Es ist halt nur ein Knopf und der hat so das Gefühl eines Back-Buttons irgendwie immer. Wenn man irgendwas abbrechen will, drückt man da drauf oder wenn man zurück will, drückt man drauf. Aber komplett falsch. Das ist der Home-Button. Man kommt damit nur zum Home-Screen von diesem Phone. Das ist so die einzige Funktion, die dieser Button hat. Beziehungsweise inzwischen kommt man auch auf die erste Seite der Apps, die man installiert hat, was auch noch hilfreich ist.
Das heißt, das Dogma, was dahinter steht, ist sozusagen, wir gehen gar nicht viele Hierarchien ein, sondern du bist halt entweder irgendwo oder du bist in der Heimat. Aber du kannst nicht durch 50 Ebenen durchmarschieren.
Gemischt, zumindest nicht mit diesem Knopf. Also alles andere passiert halt on-Screen. Die Apps selber haben schon ein bisschen Hierarchie wiederum, aber sie haben jetzt nicht so eine Hierarchiedecke wie bei Android, wo du jetzt wirklich so einen Stack von Applikationen hast, die du da rein nach bedient hast. Und dann kannst du diesen Stack zurück hüpfen, so wie mit App-tab auf dem Mac selber auch so. Zwischen den Apps, die laufen, zurück. Nee, es läuft eine App und der Rest ist dann über Home und muss da wieder hin navigiert werden.
Ja, und auch auf der Ebene so grundsätzlich der, in Anführungszeichen, Taskmanager, also wo du halt starten kannst und gucken kannst, was gerade so passiert. Und das Programm, da ist dann ganz klar irgendwie, das sind weniger Hierarchien, als man sie so kennt, weil es sind dann nur die zwei quasi. Klar, innerhalb der Applikation kannst du natürlich dann irgendwie da irgendwelche Drill-Down-Interfaces haben oder was auch immer, aber so diese zwei Ebenen, die man hat, das Ganze ist schon einfacher, denke ich.
Und der Button ist sozusagen auch nicht unter Kontrolle der Software. Also man kann nicht diesen Button als Eingabe verwenden, sondern die Eingabe erfolgt nach wie vor komplett über den Bildschirm. Und alle Knöpfe, die dran sind, sind eigentlich nur das System.
Genau, also alle angeschlossenen Knöpfe sind wirklich Systembelegungen, die ändert sich nicht. Der Homebutton macht immer das Gleiche. Doppelklick auf dem Homebutton führt noch woanders hin. Die Lautstärke-Dinger werden vom System kontrolliert. Der Vibrations-An- und Ausschaltknopf, was ein schöner Switch-Knopf ist, was alle Telefone bräuchten, finde ich, der macht auch immer immer das Gleiche. Und der Ausschaltknopf rechts oben auch. Also die einzelnen Applikationen oder unterschiedlichen Kontexte, indem du das Phone bedienst, ändern die Belegung nicht. Was irgendwie Sicherheit gibt, finde ich, in der Bedienung, weil das ist bei anderen Telefonen anders.
Zweite Eingabe-Möglichkeit, die es dann aber doch noch gibt, sind die zahlreichen Sensoren, die das Gerät bietet. Welche sind da für die Entwickler zugänglich?
Ja, mittlerweile eigentlich doch fast alle wesentlichen. Also Beschleunigungssensoren, Accelerometer, kriegst du ganz fein über die API. Den Näherungssensor kriegst du nicht. Da ist ja so ein kleiner Annäherungssensor drin, mit dem man feststellt, ob du es jetzt gerade ans Gesicht hältst oder nicht.
Genau, was natürlich wichtig ist bei so was. Sonst wählst du Nummern oder so, wenn du es ans Gesicht hältst, zum Telefonieren.
Richtig, aber der ist offiziell zumindest nicht zugänglich. Da gibt es natürlich auch Leute, die sich da reinhacken, unter anderem Google, aber so offiziell ist der nicht verfügbar.
Und dann natürlich noch GPS und den kriegt man direkt auch nicht, aber halt über eine API abstrahiert, weil erste Version vom iPhone hat, der kein GPS, neue hat. Dazwischen liegt eine API, die einem abstrakt praktisch die Location gibt.
Ja, also da läuft halt Call Location, heißt das ganze viel. Und das abstrahiert halt auch die Positionsfindung per Skyhook und Waveline, die man so sieht.
Das heißt, das Programm weiß eigentlich gar nicht, woher der Ort kommt, sondern man sagt einfach nur, hallo, liebes Telefon, ich wüsste jetzt ganz gerne mal, wo ich gerade bin. Und dann werden unterschiedliche...
Genau, du kriegst nicht offiziell gesagt, so das kommt jetzt von der GPS-Sensorik. Aber du kriegst natürlich den Genauigkeitsbereich. Und wenn da irgendwie steht, das ist jetzt auf drei Meter genau, dann kommt es halt zur Zeit von GPS. Relativ offensichtlich dann.
Aber ist ein schöner Schritt, weil, wie gesagt, GPS haben sie erst mal der zweiten Version eingebaut, aber vorher schon eine allgemeine API gehabt. Das heißt, alle Dinge, die es genutzt haben, haben einfach funktioniert und waren genauer. Sehr schön.
Und konnten sozusagen GPS benutzen, ohne zu wissen, dass es auf einmal da war. Ganz pfiffig eigentlich. Ähm, warte mal, was hatten wir jetzt für Sensoren? Jaja, genau, der Beschleunigungssensor. Wie funktioniert denn ein Beschleunigungssensor? Also wie redet man mit dem Beschleunigungssensor? Wie er funktioniert, weiß ich nicht, ob ihr das beantworten könnt, aber...
Also von der API her redet man mit dem Beschleunigungssensor relativ einfach. Man sagt, wie oft man Updates haben will von den Daten und dann kriegt man einen Callback, indem man so drei Zahlen, x, y, z, bekommt, die eben die Beschleunigungswerte darstellen für die Achsen und dann kann man damit machen, was man will.
Und in welchen... also was kriegt man da so für Werte? Also einen Stundenkilometer wird sicherlich nicht ausgerückt werden.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau, was die Einheit ist. Das sind so Werte zwischen mehr oder weniger minus eins und eins. Und alles, was weiter ausschlägt, sind halt wirklich ganz aktive Bewegungen. Und alles, was so in dem Bereich bleibt, sind mehr oder weniger die Lage, die aktuelle Position von dem Ding.
Also es ist so ein reiner relatives Maß. Das ist, glaube ich, keine großartige Maß-Einheit, die da zurückkommt.
Und was ist dann... du hast gesagt, es gibt x, y und z.
Genau.
Was ist dann was? Also wenn ich jetzt sozusagen das Telefon in der Hand habe...
Ich glaube, das Koordinatensystem ist so, wie man es denken würde. Also wenn du es in der Hand hast, ist y nach oben und x nach links, rechts und z.
Was ist denn jetzt oben?
Wenn du so draufguckst, so...
Wenn ich es hebe. Oder wenn ich es nach vorne schiebe.
Aber das kann man nachgucken.
Da gibt es Grafiken dafür und man kann natürlich, wenn man es in der Lage behält, wo es ist, wackelt in diese Dimension, dann kriegt man genau eben da starke Ausschläge. Wenn man die Lage verändert langsam, dann ändern sich einfach die Basiswerte. Man kann diese Werte mit so einem Tiefpassfilter belegen, wo man praktisch die ganzen Hochausschläge herausfiltert, dann hat man mehr oder weniger nur die Lage. Das ist zum Beispiel das, was im Sample Code von dem Teapot passiert, wo man den Teekessel so angucken kann, wenn man das Ding um sich rumhält. Oder man kann sich auf die hochfrequenten Dinger einlassen und dann irgendwelche, der hat jetzt dreimal geschüttelt Situationen ableiten davon. Aber man muss es selber tun, also das ist nicht so, man kriegt jetzt kein abstrahiertes, das wurde jetzt geschüttelt oder es liegt jetzt anders im Raum.
Aber es gibt auch nur diesen einen Sensor, also man kann, weil ich meine, wenn ich jetzt X, Y und Z habe, dann kann ich zwar eine Bewegung in irgendeine Richtung machen, aber was ist, wenn ich das Ding sozusagen um seine eigene Achse rotiere, dann ändert sich ja im Prinzip keiner dieser drei Werte.
Doch.
Na welcher denn? Wenn ich jetzt davon ausgehe, dass der Sensor wirklich in der Mitte des Gerätes ist und ich rotiere das Teil um sich herum in irgendeiner Richtung, dann...
Die Lage ist da mit drin, wie das genau technisch funktioniert.
Die Lage ist mit dran.
Die Lage ist mit drin. Wenn du ganz langsam bewegst, ist das T-Pod-Beispiel wirklich so um die eigene Achse, so siehst du es. Die Lage ist nur nicht so perfekt, wie sie sein könnte. Das ist ja eigentlich eher was, was man mit einem Gyroskop dann wirklich ganz toll messen kann. Aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt eher so was auf der E-Technik-Ecke, wo ich keinen Schimmer habe.
Keinen Platzenschimmer haben.
Da fragst du grad die Falschen.
Ich war halt nur doof.
Das Spannende ist eigentlich, wie wertet man die Dinge aus? Bei der V-Mode zum Beispiel ist ja auch nur ein Accelerometer drin, also bei der Nintendo Wii, bei der Fernbedienung. Was auch dazu führt, dass einige Spiele, die jetzt nicht von Nintendo kommen, genau diese Daten, die sind eigentlich nahezu die gleichen, schlecht auswerten und dann eben nicht gut erkannt werden. Also man kann da wahnsinnig viel machen mit dem, was hinter der Auswertung, hinter den Zahlen steckt.
Da kommen dann die heiligen Filter und dann fallen da gute Daten hinten raus.
Die heiligen Filter. Okay, jetzt runden wir mal sozusagen den technischen Systemoverview ab, was wir noch nicht besprochen haben. Was die Eingabe betrifft, da ist da noch so eine Kamera drin, aber ich glaube, die ist nicht weiter der Rede wert.
Da ist mir lieber still. Es hat auch eine Kamera. Die bei Tageslicht gut funktioniert.
Es hat so eine Kamera, die ist aber jetzt auch nicht besonders integriert. Also alles, was man mit der Kamera machen kann, wenn ich es bisher richtig gesehen habe, von dem Programm, ist so, mach mir mal ein Foto und gib mir das.
Genau.
Über die offizielle API kriegst du halt einen Assistenten, wo du halt sagen kannst, so, jetzt lass den mal ein Foto machen und dann bist du erst mal irgendwie außen vor und kannst dann irgendwann das Foto zurück.
Man kann nicht selber rauskommen?
Man kann nicht selber rauskommen. Man kann deswegen auch nicht eine Video-App schreiben, offiziell. Also man müsste in offizielle Wege gehen, was man nicht darf. Man darf auf eine sehr, sehr geschlossene Plattform dahin gehen.
Genau, da wollen wir auf jeden Fall auch noch drüber reden. Aber was natürlich recht wichtig ist, sind sozusagen die Netzwerk-Fähigkeiten von dem Gerät, die sich nutzen lassen.
Die da wären Wi-Fi, was sehr schön ist und schnell, aber nicht N, sondern G, ist das G überhaupt oder nur B? Mist. Boah, wieder schlecht informiert, aber nicht N.
B und G ist es.
B und G ist es. Und dann natürlich Telefonstandards, Edge, 3G, GSM.
Da gibt es ja immer relativ viel Konfusion, was das so ist. Also im Prinzip ist es halt, es kann sowohl GSM, als auch jetzt mit der neuen Version kann es eben auch UMTS und in beiden Netzwerken gibt es Datendienste in langsam und in schnell. Und das alte Gerät konnte halt GSM in langsam und in schnell und das neue kann halt auch UMTS in langsam und in schnell. Zumindest was den Download betrifft, nicht so sehr was den Upload betrifft.
Da geht es noch schneller.
Da ging es noch schneller. Ja, das wird ja auch. Es ist eigentlich auch ganz interessant zu sehen, dass eigentlich UMTS in zunehmendem. Maße eigentlich alles abdecken kann, was man derzeit meint, nur mit WLAN machen zu können. Also schnell das Netz rein, raus, überall. Ich denke, das wird mit UMTS schneller erzielt sein als mit WLAN. Ich meine, wie häufig hast du irgendwo WLAN?
Ich bin natürlich überall, aber ich bin auch meistens an Orten, wo ich Menschen kenne oder zu Hause.
Na ja, aber das ist jetzt auch schon eine sehr urban zentrierte Sicht der Dinge, glaube ich.
Das denke ich auch. Na ja, das ist nicht so wichtig. Wir halten einfach nur fest, das Ding kann irgendwie funken und es kann irgendwie Daten funken. Aber ich meine, was man jetzt früher von anderen Telefonen so kannte, ist, dass ja eigentlich dieser ganze Netzwerk-Kram sehr explizit zustande kommen muss. Also da hatte man dann tausend Sachen, wo man sich dann einwählen muss und noch Datenverbindungen auswählen muss und so. Wie ist denn das beim iPhone gelöst? Also was ist sozusagen die Sicht des Programmierers auf diese Netzwerkdienste?
Also grundsätzlich ist es mal politisch von Apple so gelöst, dass die offiziellen Verträge alle eine mehr oder weniger Daten-Flatrate mitbringen. Also der unterste Tarif in Deutschland jetzt nicht mehr, aber es war eigentlich so angedacht. Das heißt, das Gerät sollte mal den Eindruck vermitteln, immer online. Also das ist mal so Situation, die man den Benutzern so eigentlich mitgibt. Von der technischen Seite her kann man über eine API rausfinden, über welche Wege man gerade online ist, weil es gibt ja durchaus auch Ecken der Welt, die jetzt keinen Datentarif haben für mich oder die auch überhaupt keine GSM oder UMTS-Verbindungen mir liefern, wo ich einfach keine Verbindung habe, kann ich abfragen.
Es gibt halt umgekehrt auch den Fall, dass du als Programm manche Sachen halt nicht machen willst, wenn du jetzt nicht über Waveline angebunden bist zum Beispiel.
Genau, auch das oder nicht machen darfst. Zum Beispiel Voice over IP darf man laut Apple nur über WLAN machen.
Aber was sagt einem dann das Gerät? Also das sagt, du hast jetzt zwar Internet, aber du hast Internet über Funk.
Genau.
Also nicht über nicht WLAN sozusagen.
Es gibt da eine API, die fragt mal, wie bin ich denn gerade verbunden und dann sagt mir die grundsätzlich, ja, da gibt es so eine Website, die kannst du erreichen. Und du bist jetzt gerade über diese Art und Weise unterwegs. Also entweder eben, ich glaube, entweder Telefon oder Wi-Fi. Ich glaube, die Unterscheidung zwischen Edge und UMTS und so weiter wird gar nicht so getroffen auf der Ebene.
Ich muss sagen, das ist auch nur interessant. Also das musst du nur machen, wenn es dich wirklich interessiert. Also an sich ist das Netzwerk für den Programmierer schon sehr transparent gelöst. Also wenn es dir wirklich nur darum geht, ich brauche jetzt Netz, ich will jetzt was machen, dann musst du dich gar nicht groß dafür interessieren, ob das jetzt UMTS oder Waveline ist.
Das heißt eigentlich genauso, wie man das vom Desktop-Computer auch kennt, dass einem eigentlich gar nicht klar ist, wo der Computer jetzt das Internet herholt, Hauptsache, es kommt irgendwie ran.
Also im Falle von unserem Twitter-Klein kann man einfach mal so die Anfrage an die entsprechende API stellen und dann kommt halt ein Timeout zurück und dann war ich wohl nicht im Netz. Also man kann es auch komplett ignorieren.
Gut, das heißt, ja, das bringt uns jetzt eigentlich zu dem eigentlichen Thema, wie ich finde, nämlich dem Betriebssystem selber. Das iPhone ist ja insofern auch etwas Besonderes, als dass es das Betriebssystem von einem Desktop-Computer nimmt, nämlich im Prinzip das Mac OS X. Klar, es gibt jetzt auch Telefone, die mit Linux laufen, gar keine Frage, sind dann aber auch sehr abgespeckte Varianten und verwenden in der Regel auch kein ähnliches GUI. Aber Apple hat ja auch große Teile des User-Interfaces, also zumindest der Frameworks dieser User-Interfaces mit übernommen. Ich bewege mich hier auf dünnen Eis, weil es ist natürlich offensichtlich, dass gerade die Benutzung des iPhones eben ganz anders ist, da bin ich ja auch mit eingestiegen. Aber fragen wir einfach mal so, was hat denn Apple jetzt quasi vom Macintosh tatsächlich aufs iPhone rübergebracht und was wurde weggelassen?
Ich glaube, als Daumenregel alles, was bunt ist, haben sie erstmal weggelassen. Alles, was so Grafik macht und lustig Pixel zeichnet und so für den wesentlichen bunten quasi Anteil des Ganzen verantwortlich ist, haben sie erstmal gesagt so außen vor. Wir konzentrieren uns jetzt mal darauf, dass wir OS-Tender grundsätzlich auf Arm porten und das mal so bootet und launcht, die läuft und solche Geschichten. Und dann haben sie halt wirklich überlegt, wie machen wir für dieses Telefon die UI-Frameworks so neu, dass es zusammenpasst.
Also in gewisser Hinsicht hast du ja nicht recht, weil die eigentlichen Grafik-Frameworks sind doch dieselben oder sind die anders?
Das ist ganz gemischt. Wenn wir jetzt konkret die Grafik-Frameworks nehmen, Quartz läuft auf dem Ding, also ich kann meine Vektor-Bézier-Kurven zeichnen, aber nicht in Cocoa. Also ich muss die C-API benutzen, Core-Graphics zum Beispiel. Die Art und Weise, wie Knöpfe gemalt werden, ist grundsätzlich ähnlich, kann ich mit Quartz malen, praktisch wird es aber mehr mit OpenGL gelöst und mit Layers als mit der Quartz-API. Und das ist so eine Geschichte, was ja auf dem Mac mit LayerKit jetzt hinterher kam, mit Core-Animation, ich nenne es noch LayerKit, das ist ja ganz alt, also mit Core-Animation kam ist im Endeffekt das, was fürs iPhone entwickelt wurde. Also da ist es den umgekehrten Weg gegangen. Sie haben fürs iPhone was gebraucht, damit sie auf der Plattform schön Animationen usw. machen und haben es dann backgeportet auf Mac OS X.
Ja, also das fand ich auch eine interessante Geschichte. Also Core-Animation kennt man ja schon ein bisschen länger, weil gab es ja schon vor dem iPhone, von außen betrachtet, aber das kam wirklich alles aus dieser iPhone-Entwicklung und wurde dann backgeportet auf Mac OS X.
Wer jetzt den anderen Podcast nicht mehr so ganz im Kopf hat, sollten wir vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen, was Core-Animation ist. Also Core-Animation setzt quasi auf den darunter liegenden Grafik-Layern auf, aber wenn ich euch jetzt richtig verstehe, nicht direkt auf Quarz, also...
Also Core-Animation selber ist... Also grundsätzlich ist Core-Animation wirklich ein Framework, das Animationen erlaubt auf Grafikpuffern, auf Hardware-Grafikpuffern grundsätzlich. Das heißt, ich habe hier meine Vier-Ecke, das sind meine Hardware-Grafikpuffer und ich sage dann, okay, geh mal bitte an die Position in der Geschwindigkeit, danach an die Position mit der Geschwindigkeit und der Animationskurve und mach das dann einfach mal und danach muss ich mich nicht mehr drum kümmern. Ja, das ist das, was Core-Animation eigentlich an sich macht.
Das heißt, man beschreibt so quasi so eine Szenerie und sagt, jetzt mach mal.
Genau, ich habe, die Szenerie ist in hierarchischen Layern gestaltet eigentlich, ja, das sind eben die Core-Animation-Layer und mit diesen Layern kann ich arbeiten. Und die Layer selber haben halt einen Pixel-Content in irgendeiner Form, das kann entweder ein Bild sein oder ich kann da reinzeichnen, programmatisch. Und das ist die Art und Weise, wie es wirklich auf dem iPhone funktioniert. Auf dem Mac ist es andersrum, weil auf dem Mac ist es so, dass du die ganz normale Coco-Hierarchie normalerweise hast, die halt aus NSFuse besteht, in die du programmatisch reinzeichnest mit Quartz. Du machst dann irgendwelche Buttons, in denen du halt einen Oval zeichnest und dann eine Füllung oder ein Pixelbild dahin malst, wirklich über diese API.
Also sehr High-Level.
Genau, und was sie da gemacht haben, ist du kannst gleichzeitig sagen, hey, mach mich mal layer-backed. Dann malst du das alles, was du so malst, in einen Layer und den kannst du dann auch wieder animieren. Das heißt, sie haben genau diese Technologie benutzt und die integriert in das normale NSFuse-System.
Das findet da halt mehr hinter den Kulissen statt für dich.
Genau, und auf dem iPhone ist das ganz, ganz explizit. Du hast deine CA-Layers und die kannst du benutzen und animieren und da kannst du was reinmalen oder nicht. Aber das sind jetzt keine NSFuse und das ist wirklich viel sauberer von der Basis her. Also sie mussten diese Kompatibilitätsschicht halt nicht machen.
Wenn du sagst sauberer, das ist, glaube ich, was man auch irgendwie merkt, wenn man beides kennt. Da haben sich die nochmal hingesetzt, Kaffee getrunken und gesagt, so jetzt machen wir das neu und gut. Und nicht so mal langsam gewachsen und irgendwie mit Ideen, die halt irgendwie früher Sinn gemacht haben, aber mittlerweile mit der neuen Hardware nicht mehr unbedingt Sinn machen, einfach nochmal neu ausgedacht und anders gemacht. Und da merkst du schon an allen Stellen, da haben sie die gleichen Konzepte mit moderneren Mitteln gelöst.
Genau, und das zieht sich eigentlich komplett durch. Also deine Aussage von wegen, sie haben alles aus Bundes erst mal dargelassen und dann Teile von dem, was bunt ist, mitgenommen und verändert und neu gemacht, trifft vollkommen zu. Also auch auf die höherliegende, was man in UI-Kit alles mit den Buttons machen kann, das sind auch schöne Dinge, die man unter Coco auf dem Mac noch nicht machen kann. Zum Beispiel das Target-Action-Geschichte. Man kann unter Coco auf dem Mac einem Knopf sagen, wenn du gedrückt wirst, dann sende bitte diese Methode an dieses Objekt. Was ganz schön ist, weil dann kann man das so von außen steuern. Was man auf dem iPhone jetzt machen kann, ist, man kann diesem Button sagen, nur wenn jetzt der Finger hochgeht an der Stelle, sende diese Action an dieses Objekt. Wenn der Finger außerhalb hochgeht, sende diese andere Action an dieses andere Objekt. Man kann das viel weiter parametrisieren, ohne dass man jetzt wieder direkt in diese Control-Code reinstecken muss, der das dann wieder auswertet. Also man merkt, da ist ein Evolutionsschritt passiert. Und ich warte eigentlich schon, dass ich die wieder zurückkriege auf den Mac.
Also das ist auch etwas, was ich mit anderen Mac-Entwicklern auch schon öfter diskutiert habe. Wenn man mal auf dem iPhone war und dann zurückgeht, in Anführungszeichen, auf den Mac, ist das zuerst so ein bisschen eine Überwindung. Weil man merkt so, oh, das ist der alte Scheiß. Es macht natürlich trotzdem irrem Spaß, nach wie vor mit Mac zu entwickeln, aber man merkt so, ah, so könnte es sein. Und da warten wir dann momentan drauf, dass es besser wird.
Weil gleichzeitig hatten wir ja alles untenrum. Also wir haben ja damals in den Podcasts gesagt, es ist ja so eine Trennung zwischen Foundation, das ist eben das, was nicht bunt ist eigentlich, und UpKit auf dem Mac oder UIKit auf dem iPhone. Und in der Foundation hast du so gut wie alles. Also alles, was irgendwie mit Datensstrukturen zu tun hat. Deine Dictionaries, deine Arrays, dein CF-Network, deine NS-Streams. Also eigentlich so alles, was du so untenrum an Basisfunktionität vom Computer haben willst, hast du auf der Ebene. Und das, was du im UIKit hast, ist halt anders.
Also hast du auch auf dem iPhone.
Hast du auch auf dem iPhone, im großen Teil. Also eben abgesehen zum Beispiel vom Zeichnen. Zeichnen musst du über die C-Routinen machen, kannst du nicht über die Coco-Routinen machen. Ist aber auch kein großes Problem. Es sind im Endeffekt die gleichen Calls, nur ein bisschen länger. Die Abstraktion, die da auf Coco-Seite passiert, ist nicht so groß. Also die Rapper-Klassen könnte man sich auch schnell selber schreiben. Das ist wirklich okay. Ich kann jetzt nicht so einfach da einen anderen Font benutzen. Und deshalb muss ich mir jetzt da zwei Seiten Code irgendwo besorgen. Aber es ist nicht wirklich was, was einen massiv stört. Und in der UI haben sie eben schöne neue Dinge reingebracht.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal dazu. Also Kern, meine Frage war ja, was wurde weggelassen, was kam hinzu? Im Prinzip, das Kernbetriebssystem als solches ist vollständig da. Und auch diese Foundation, also diese sozusagen Zwischenebene, diese unbunte Zwischenebene, ist vollständig da. Also man kann quasi aus demselben Topf schöpfen von Datenstrukturen und niedriglevel Netzzugängen etc. Infrastruktur, schönes Wort. Und was aber komplett anders ist, ist die Art und Weise, wie man an das User-Interface herangeht, sowohl was jetzt eine bestimmte Funktionalität betrifft, als auch, naja, wie es ebenso funktioniert. Wie würdet ihr denn den Unterschied beschreiben? Ich meine, so auf dem Desktop ist ja alles mit der Maus so. Man geht also davon aus, dass man so ein Pointing-Device hat, was immer da ist. Jetzt gibt es ein anderes Pointing-Device, das ist der Finger. Verhält sich der Finger wie eine Maus? Oder wie sieht man als Programmierer den Menschen, der diese Software benutzt?
Ja, als Programmierer. Ich weiß nicht, als Programmierer macht es jetzt für dich nicht so einen wahnsinnigen Unterschied. Wenn du nur technisch betrachtest, von ganz unten rauf guckst, du hast keine Mouse-Over-Events oder solche Geschichten, sondern du hast halt irgendwie Drücke und Finger, die sich bewegen.
Also du kannst nicht die Maus über irgendeinem Ding drüber haben und dann tust du nur was, weil die Maus da drüber fliegt, weil gibt es halt nicht.
Wenn du das Ding berührst, dann berührst du das Ding. Es gibt keinen State, in dem du quasi über dem Ding schwebst.
Das ist so der Hauptunterschied eigentlich. Es gibt diese Nicht-Click-Situation, die gibt es nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum es keinen Flashgipfel ist.
Wahrscheinlich, weil da doch bricht schon einiges. Also es ist auch ein großer Ding, wo es auf dem Webkit, auf diesen Web-Applikations-Ecke immer gesagt haben, es gibt kein Hover, es gibt kein Hover.
Also Hover im Sinne von drüber schweben, genau, dieser Event, der da erzeugt wird.
Aber ich glaube, der wesentliche Unterschied ist gar nicht auf der Ebene als Programmierer, sondern wirklich auf der Ebene als UI-Designer. Weil du durch den Screen und durch die andere Interaktion viel drüber nachdenken musst, wie du Dinge anders machen musst. Und dass es sich richtig anfühlt und dass es Sinn macht als Interface.
Ich würde das jetzt auch nicht unbedingt bei den Fingern anfangen lassen. Ich meine, das ist klar, wir haben jetzt nur Finger, aber es ist schon allein der Lebenszyklus von so einer App. Wie ist es denn? Auf dem Desktop starte ich und dann ist sie da. Dann benutze ich sie, dann habe ich ein Fenster davon. Dann tue ich das Fenster in den Hintergrund, dann gucke ich da wieder drauf, dann tue ich es wieder im Vordergrund. Da habe ich die Situation, mehrere Programme laufen gleichzeitig. Auf dem iPhone ist ein Programm in Fullscreen am Start und der Rest halt nicht. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz großer Wechsel. Das heißt, wenn ich erst mal in meinem Programm rausgehe, um jetzt mal was in meinem Kalender nachzugucken, und dann in meinem Programm wieder zurückkomme, dann ist mein Programm zwischenzeitlich beendet worden. Das heißt, ich muss eine bewusste Entscheidung treffen. Soll es jetzt so sein, dass ich wieder an die selbe Stelle komme, wo ich vorher war? Oder soll es so sein, dass meine App immer so hochkommt, wie sie hochkommt? Das kommt drauf an. Also man muss ganz, ganz grundsätzliche Entscheidungen schon mal im Vorfeld treffen, weil die Benutzungsstruktur einfach eine ganz andere ist als auf dem Desktop.
Es ist auch eine ganz andere… Du musst auch ganz andere Gedanken machen, wie viel Information du gleichzeitig vermittelst. Also bei Apple gibt es dieses geflügelte Wort von dem Screenful, nennen sie das. Und das ist halt eine Einheit, die sie sich da irgendwie ausgedacht haben, für was Sinn macht, auf einem Bildschirm zu sein an Bedienelementen und an Informationen und Fuse.
Ein Schirm voll Daten.
Ein Schirm voll Daten, genau.
Und wie viel ist das dann? Wie viel Daten geht auf den Schirm?
Ja, so fünf oder sieben, je nachdem. Wie messen die das? Ne, gemessen wird da natürlich nichts. Das ist eine abstrakte Idee.
Oder wie definieren sie denn den Screen voll?
Sie definieren hauptsächlich darüber so, guck, was wir machen, und halt dich da so in etwa dran.
Ja, das ist ja natürlich ein Spaß. Das ist natürlich insgesamt eine gute Idee, wenn man eine konsistente Plattform haben will. Das ist auf dem Desktop eine gute Idee. Guck, was Apple macht und mach so ähnlich. Nur mal so, weil es jetzt so ins Lächerliche gezogen wurde.
Ich meine, man weiß ja, wie es ist. Wenn du es nicht so machst, wie wir es machen, dann hat es keine Berechtigung. Das ist natürlich auch etwas, was immer mal wieder hochkommt in der Apple-Welt.
Diese Idee ist auf jeden Fall eine, wo viel Bauchgefühl auch mit reinspielt ist. Du siehst ganz klar, wenn es komplett in die Wiese gelaufen ist, wenn da 100 Knöpfe auf einem Bildschirm sind und noch 20 andere Controls, dann ist es zu viel. Und umgekehrt, wenn da alles beißt, dann ist es zu wenig. Wo dann die genaue Richtgröße ist, die da jetzt eingehalten werden muss oder nicht, das ist ein unscharfer Bereich.
Ihr wart ja, ich das richtig erinnere, wann kam das iPhone raus? Letztes Jahr im Juli, oder? Und ja, da war erst mal das gewesen groß und alle wollten dafür programmieren.
Und dann hat Apple gesagt, ja, könnt ihr super, könnt ihr irgendwie Web-Apps schreiben, das ist voll toll.
Ja, ist es. Ja, das war so ganz interessant zu sehen. Aber man merkte auf jeden Fall, dass ein riesen Bedarf da war, bei den Programmierern für diese Plattform zu entwickeln. Also jeder wollte sofort instantan dafür Software machen. Ich glaube, ich das genauso wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich meine, es war halt auch so diese Geschichte, Steve stellt sich da vorne hin und sagt so, hey, wir haben hier Mac OS X, wir haben hier QuickTime. Es ist so alles, was ihr kennt, auf dieser kleinen Plattform. Und wir haben eine sweet solution for you to develop for it. Und du denkst dir, oh cool, ja, so Xcode, Coco, geil, Telefon. Klar, da war dann natürlich das Bedürfnis da, sozusagen, ja, ich will mit den Tools, die ich kenne und gern habe, will ich auch für dieses Telefon entwickeln. Weil im Prinzip ist es ja nichts anderes als ein Mac. Und ich will auch die Mac-Tools benutzen können. Und da war natürlich das Bedürfnis groß.
Es sollte aber dann eben noch ein bisschen dauern. Irgendwann haben sie dann im Prinzip genau diesen Schritt gemacht. Ich meine, ich denke mal, die waren wahrscheinlich erst mal auch so, damit beschäftigt dieses Gerät überhaupt erst mal zum Laufen zu kriegen, dass sie sich jetzt nicht das gleich sozusagen mit Set Party da versauen lassen wollten. Aber sie haben ja dann relativ schnell nachgezogen. So, dann war es Mitte dieses Jahres soweit. Und ihr seid dann ja relativ zügig danach zur Worldwide Developers Konferenz hingefahren, habt euch das irgendwie einmal erklären lassen. Durftet dann keinem davon erzählen, weil bis vor kurzem ja noch ein dickes, fettes Schloss über dieser ganzen Informationspolitik drüber hing. Da kann man auch gleich nochmal drüber reden. Aber worauf ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, dass ich das richtig erinnere, habt ihr noch auf dem Rückweg im Flugzeug angefangen, eure erste Applikation zu entwickeln.
Eigentlich noch viel krasser.
Noch krasser, ja, ja. Jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Weil wir waren eine Woche vorher da, so ein bisschen mal akklimatisieren und Freunde besuchen. Wie in San Francisco ist das. Und haben uns dann halt da in dem Kontext schon vor der BBC zusammengesetzt und angefangen zu schreiben und sich da mal einzuarbeiten in die Doku, um dann eben möglichst viel mitzunehmen von dem, was man dann auf der BBC so erzählt bekommt und um auch Fragen stellen zu können, wenn man mal die Gelegenheit hat, mit den Leuten, die das so verbrochen haben, dann direkt zu konferieren.
Weil das ist so ein grundsätzlicher Hinweis, wenn man jetzt überlegt, auf die BBC zu gehen. Man sollte das tun, wenn man ein konkretes Projekt vor dem Bauch hat oder schon ein konkretes Projekt gemacht hat und schon ein bisschen so einfach in den Bereichen drin ist. Weil mit dem Hauptwert an dieser Veranstaltung ist, dass man in die Labs gehen kann und dort Apple-Entwickler fragen, wie mache ich den X, wie mache ich den Y? Und diese Fragen hat man nicht nach dem Vortrag. Weil, okay, das ist alles super und toll und das geht klasse. Aber die entscheidenden Fragen bekommt man eigentlich, wenn man selber was macht mit der API und dann merkt, okay, wie mache ich das jetzt so oder so oder so? Und dann ist einfach die WWDC viel wertvoller. Und aus dem Gedanken raus haben wir eben im Vorfeld schon uns das ein bisschen angeeignet und die App gestartet, sodass wir praktisch währenddessen auch schon richtigen Fragen stellen konnten. Und es war in dem Fall auch sehr wichtig, dass wir das währenddessen gemacht haben, weil ja, da gab es einige spannende Dinge, die wir da gelernt haben.
Na was denn so? Also ich meine, worauf ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, ihr habt euch nicht viel Zeit gelassen, um eure erste Applikation loszutreten. Und ich schätze mal, danach ist man immer schlauer. Was sind denn so die typischen Stolperfallen, in die ihr dann auch hineingerannt seid oder die ihr vielleicht durch gute Tipps auch gleich habt vermeiden können? Also wie soll ich fragen? Also eigentlich, was ich gerne wissen will, ist so, wie ist es sozusagen, also wie geht man heran an so eine Applikation und was habt ihr aus euren ersten Fehlern da auch schon lernen können?
Insgesamt war das Ganze relativ schmerzfrei, muss ich sagen. Also es hört sich jetzt dumm an, aber mir fällt jetzt spontan kein Fehler wirklich ein, wo ich sagen würde, das werde ich jetzt komplett anders machen. Also wir haben unsere Methodik, die wir von Mac-Apps kennen, mal so erstmal versucht, eins zu eins zu verwenden, auch fürs iPhone. Sprich, man fängt irgendwie an mit Ideen, mit Photoshop-Mockups, mit Bleistiftzeichnungen von einem Interface, überlegt sich dann, wie läuft da die Interaktionskurve, wo drücke ich hin, was passiert dann, wenn ich da drücke, wie komme ich da in die Tiefe von der App rein. Man kannte ja dieses Interface vom iPhone schon zu genüge, weil man eben nicht gleich am Anfang draufgeschmissen wurde, ohne jetzt irgendwie Erfahrung zu haben.
Du hast ja schon ein Jahr damit rumgeklickt.
Man hat es ja schon rumgeklickt damit ewig. Und insofern hatte man da auch schon so ein gewisses Gefühl für die Bedienkonzepte zumindest. Und so in dieser Prototypenphase haben wir da eigentlich, hat das eigentlich funktioniert einfach.
Es gab halt ein paar Sachen, die habe ich jetzt so konkret nicht mehr im Kopf, aber wo halt in, auf der WDC die entscheidende Richtungsweisung passierte. Kleine Details.
Wenn du halt überlegst, wie groß darf jetzt dieser Knopf sein, dass man ihn noch trifft zum Beispiel. Da kannst du natürlich, zu dem Zeitpunkt war der Apple Design Guide noch nicht draußen und es gab halt nur die API-Doku. Da überlegst du halt irgendwie Größe. Also keine Ahnung, 20, 30, 40, 50 Pixel. Auf der WDC bekommst du dann gesagt, ja, so macht man mindestens 40 Pixel.
Weil so groß ist ein Finger.
Genau, so groß ist der Standard Apple Finger.
Was kriegt man denn da für eine Information, wenn man da so mit dem Finger drauf tappt? Kriegt man dann sozusagen den Mittelpunkt dessen, wo man gedrückt hat und dann denkt man sich sozusagen den Umkreis drum herum?
Ja, du kriegst halt den Mittelpunkt, wohin gezielt wurde, den Umkreis. Ja, wenn du willst, kannst du dir den dazudenken, aber...
Also du kriegst nicht so einen kompletten Fettfinger. Du kriegst nicht so wie bei der Location, so das GPS irgendwie plus, minus zehn Meter, dass du so kriegst, hier wurde jetzt draufgetippt, plus, minus zehn Pixel oder so. So was ist es nicht.
Du kriegst einen Punkt.
Genau, du kriegst einen Punkt und du kriegst so die...
Das heißt, man weiß nicht, wie dick die Finger sind, die es benutzt haben.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ja, vielleicht auch eine interessante Information.
Lass uns das andere noch mal abschließen. Was uns da wirklich geholfen hat, war, wirklich auch auf der WebIDC hat, ist man mit Sample Code beschmissen worden. Das hat geholfen. Also noch mal zu sehen, das ist die Art und Weise, wie das vorgesehen ist, weil so ein paar API doch relativ neu war und die Doku zwar gut, aber noch nicht wirklich ganz komplett war. Im Verhältnis zu dem, was bei Coco am Anfang war, war sie wirklich gut.
Ganz abgesehen davon, dass die Tools zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch unterirdischer waren, als sie zurzeit sind und irgendwie das Interface-Bild überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat.
Genau, das war so eine Kernfrage eigentlich auch so, wie benutze ich die Tools richtig und wie benutze ich die Klassen richtig im Kontext. Weil ich wusste, dass es da so einen Controller gibt, der dann irgendwas machen soll, aber wie genau muss ich die zusammenstecken, damit es stimmt. Und das hat man auf der WDC gelernt, sondern dann haben wir es gleich richtig zusammengesteckt. Also das war so ein Bereich, den haben wir am Anfang erst ein bisschen rumprobiert und dann da gemacht. Und auch die Aussage, wie viel kann man im NIP machen? Weil im Gegensatz zum Mac jetzt, NIP ist dieses Dateiformat, das im Endeffekt ist Interface als Komplettabspeicher. Mehr oder weniger Komplettabspeicherheit auf dem Mac.
NIP ist glaube ich Next-Step-Interface-Bilder, oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Und jetzt heißt es XIP inzwischen mit X vorne dran. Also nicht erschrecken, wenn man das liest, das ist auch was. Das ist die XML-Format davon und das wird dann zu einem NIP kompiliert. Alles ist ein bisschen komplizierter geworden, aber ist immer noch das Gleiche eigentlich. Aber genau, auf dem iPhone will man eigentlich auch sich so Interface zusammenklicken, denkt man sich. Passiert aber so wie nicht. Also dass man mit dem iPhone ein Interface zusammenklicken kann, ist so ganz rudimentär. Ich habe jetzt oben in meinem hierarchischen Navigationsmodell halt einen Button ganz links oben, der sagt dann OK, cancel und rechts habe ich einen anderen Button, der irgendwas sagt und unten ist dann eine View und das war's dann oder so. Es ist jetzt nicht so, wie man es sich auf dem Mac vorstellt, wenn man da schon mal so einen Pfeil aufgemacht hat, da ist im Endeffekt das ganze Fenster drin mit allen Elementen. Passiert nicht so.
Ich glaube, es liegt auch daran, dass Interface-Bilder jetzt da nicht so wahnsinnig viel Anwendung findet im Vergleich zu einer Mac-App, dass so eine iPhone-Applikation viel mehr Storyboards hat in Anführungszeichen. Das ist viel interaktionsorientierter, dieses ganze Interface, du hast viel mehr Fenster in Anführungszeichen, die du abwechselst. Und dafür ist Interface-Bilder halt irgendwie nicht gemacht. Mit 20 Fenstern, die miteinander irgendwie in einer Reihe verschieden interagieren, gut umzugehen.
Und ein großer Teil, für das eigentlich schön wäre es zu verwenden, wäre eben Table Views, also diese ganzen Listenansichten, die man so mit dem Finger durchflickt auf dem iPhone, da ist es wirklich so, da drin, jede einzelne Zelle, also jede einzelne Informationshappen sozusagen, ist eigentlich programmatisch erzeugt. Das wäre eigentlich so ein Bereich, wo man denken würde, okay, dann mache ich links mein Bild und da mein Label und da mein Label und da mein Label und das rücke ich schon mit dem Interface-Bilder hin. Das macht man programmatisch, weil das Speed kostet irgendwie. Also das ist seltsam. Also man könnte natürlich das auch aus dem Nipp laden und dann einmal so einen Prototypen im Speicher haben. Aber die ganzen Geschichten passieren noch wirklich im Code. Ich mache da einen Button und dem mache ich jetzt 40 Pixel von links und wenn der jetzt im Edit-Modus ist, dann ist er 20 Pixel von links und dann starte ich die Animation.
Das sind jetzt sozusagen Beschränkungen, die dazukommen. Vermute ich jetzt mal, dass es im Wesentlichen damit zu tun hat, weil das Gerät deutlich weniger Speicher hat als ein normaler Desktop-Computer. Auch wenn es rein von der Leistungsgeschichte ist, ist es schon so ein Computer vor 5, 6 Jahren, oder?
Ja, es ist so ein etwa G3.
Also so ein Powerbook, so ein altes, schwarzes sozusagen.
So ein Nativ auf dem G3 soll es wohl ähnlich laufen.
Das ist interessant, dass man das jetzt schon so auf Telefongröße hat. Aber man hat halt wenig Speicher, man hat halt eben auch Speed und vor allem, was jetzt auch beim Laptop nie so das Thema war, man hat natürlich auch deutlich weniger Energie und man will ja natürlich, dass das Gerät lange läuft und dass man möglichst wenig drum verbaut. Aber bevor wir vielleicht diese Aspekte nochmal beleuchten, du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, naja, du hast dich halt jetzt rangesetzt und wolltest deine iPhone-Sache machen und du warst ja durch das Benutzen quasi mit den Bedienkonzepten vertraut. Was sind denn diese Bedienkonzepte? Darauf wollte ich eigentlich so ein bisschen hinaus. Also was macht sozusagen eine Applikation jetzt auf dem iPhone wirklich aus? Was für eine Interaktion bietet man dem Anwender an und inwieweit unterscheidet sich das eben von dem klassischen Ansatz? Kannst du da Dinge benennen?
Also was ich halt jetzt gerade im Kopf, also Apple hat da irgendwie drei, vier verschiedene App-Typen, die sie da definieren. Ich kriege die gar nicht auf die Reihe jetzt mal irgendwie Entertainment und Spiele und Informationsnavigation ist so eine Geschichte, die ich halt gerade jetzt im Kopf habe. Und wenn es darum geht, große Mengen hier Productivity, Utility und Immersive sind die Kategorien. Und bei Productivity, da kommt es halt drauf an, Informationen irgendwie sinnvoll zu präsentieren auf diesem Bildschirm. Und da man meistens nicht alles da drauf kriegt gleichzeitig, inklusive der Controls, gilt es das halt irgendwie hier hierarchisch zu organisieren und dann in so ein Drill-Down-Interface zu packen.
Was heißt das?
Drill-Down. Ich habe ein Stück Information, klicke drauf und kann dann tiefer reinbohren in diese Information, sehe mehr, kann da bedienen und kann von da aus vielleicht nochmal eine Ebene tiefer reinbohren.
Das ist so dieser typische von links nach rechts Flow, den man so häufig auf dem iPhone begegnet. Man klickt irgendwas an, dann schiebt sich alles so nach links weg und dann ist der nächste View sozusagen das, was man angeklickt hat, in größer.
Und die Daten so zu organisieren, dass man die in so ein Interface reinkriegt und auch ordentlich bedienen kann, ohne dass man irgendwie ständig hin und her muss und so, das sind so die wesentlichen Herausforderungen gewesen, denke ich. Und da hilft einem halt tatsächlich, wenn man schon ein halbes Jahr mit dem Ding rumgeklickt hat und eben weiß, ah, Apple macht das hier so, da ist da der Knopf, damit ich nicht wieder auf die komplette Rutebene zurück muss und von da aus wieder woanders hinnavig gehen muss.
Eure erste ab.
Ja, ich wollte da noch was hinten dranhängen, weil, auch wenn wir es schon lange benutzt haben, also was mir damals noch nicht aufgefallen war, war so diese Geschichte so, ich zeig dir die Information gleich auf deinem ersten Screen, ja. Wenn der Screen scrollt, dann ist die Information, die du jetzt gerade suchst, höchstwahrscheinlich trotzdem im oberen Bereich. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich im Adressbuch, wenn ich im Telefon auf recent calls drücke, dann ist ganz oben so der Datum und Uhrzeit, die ist einfach oben nochmal drin beim Namen noch, die ist nicht unten. Und die Telefonnummer, von der angerufen worden ist, ist unter Umständen auch hochgefahren. Die Adresse ist weiter unten als die Telefonnummer, weil eher, wenn wir die Telefonnummer wissen, als die Adresse. Macht man dasselbe aber aus einem anderen Kontext raus, ist die Adresse oben. Also sie haben sich da viele Gedanken gemacht, dass sie auch Interaktionen sparen. So dieses selbe Modell, das ja auch, wie heißt das denn, der Palm so berühmt gemacht hat, mit minimaler Anzahl an Klicks irgendwo hinkommen. Das spielt da auch ganz massiv mit beim Design so einer App. Wie verpacke ich Informationen so, dass ich möglichst wenig Interaktionen brauche, um die gewünschte Information auch zu finden?
Eure erste Applikation war ja im Prinzip so eine Productivity-App, kann man sagen, oder?
Ja, ist ja auch immer noch.
Ist sie auch immer noch, heißt? Circulator.
Und macht? Macht so, wenn du was verleist oder was geliehen bekommst, eine Verwaltung darauf, dass du nicht vergisst, es zurückzugeben oder es wiederzubekommen.
So ein Wer schuldet mir was und wem schulde ich was und so weiter Tool. Und inwieweit, also du hast ja gesagt, das war alles schon recht schmerzfrei, das heißt, ihr habt euch das irgendwie ausgedacht und dann konntet ihr das auch relativ schnell runterkoden und es gab keine Probleme.
Gerade die UI-Ecke war wirklich erstaunlich angenehm, tatsächlich, hat Spaß gemacht, richtig gehend. So diese Ebenen drunter, sprich SQLite, da ist ja SQLite mit dabei, da irgendwie diesen Interface-Lehr zu schreiben, die Daten da rein und rauszukriegen, das war ein bisschen Aufwand, aber das hast du gemacht, oder nicht?
Ja, genau, also wenn man jetzt so gewohnt ist, vom Desktop-Core Data zu benutzen, wo man dann im Xcode selber sich seine Entity-Relation Modelle zusammenklopft und dann einfach seine Objekte rausfallen, unten ist man halt auf dem iPhone wirklich auf der CAP-i von SQL Lite.
Warum? Ist nicht so, da gibt es keine Abstraktion. Ja, aber das ist auch wirklich komisch. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite hast du gesagt, jetzt bin ich auf dem iPhone und da ist irgendwie alles schon so die Zukunft und dann muss ich wieder zu meinem Macintosh zurück, das ist ganz schlimm, das widerspricht dem doch jetzt an sich.
So schwarz-weiß ist halt nun mal nicht alles und gerade CoreData ist halt auch eine Geschichte, die ist architektonisch darauf ausgelegt worden, auf einem Desktop-Computer zu laufen. Also ich speicher hungrig und die ganze Architektur zielt halt drauf ab. Ich habe RAM und ich habe Festplatte und ich kopiere da hin und her und ich denke, da ist viel vom grundsätzlichen Design in dieser Denke gelaufen. Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es auf dem iPhone irgendwann mal mit Firmware 3.0 oder wann auch immer auch CoreData da gibt, aber das ist halt keine leichte Portierung. Und deswegen haben sie das immer weggelassen, gerade weil man, wenn man so guckt, was hin 1.0 und dann auch zu 2.0, was ja durchaus länger gedauert hat, als man so vermutet hätte, was sie da so an Arbeit reingesteckt haben, wo die Schlaglöcher waren, da war da vermutlich keine Zeit mehr, da auch noch CoreData mit reinzuporten.
Da fällt mir ein Stolperstein, ein großer Stolperstein zu dem Zeitpunkt war der Speichermangel. Das sind ja so diese 128 Megabyte RAM, die dieses Ding hat. Das iPhone hat keinen Virtual End-Speicher, also wenn der Speicher voll ist, ist er voll und dann kackt das komplett ab und ist weg, was keiner mag. Deshalb sagt das Betriebssystem, sitzt es dazwischen und wenn du an diese Grenze nahe rankommst, zu viel Speicher zu verbraten, dann sagt dir das Betriebssystem, du machst mal was frei, sonst schieße ich dich ab. Und das ist dann das, was passiert, wenn so der Bildschirm schwarz wird und wieder das Home kommt.
Dann hat das Programm sozusagen nicht reagiert in Teilen.
Genau, dann kommt das Speicher-Wattstock und sagt so, hey, jetzt haben wir mal schnell hier, räum mal auf. Und dann hat es so fünf Sekunden auf die Uhr und dann kommt er noch mal, so wenig passiert, jetzt geh mal hier bitte. Also das war gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir angefangen haben, dafür zu entwickeln, war das noch ziemlich schlecht, weil auch die Farmwärme halt dementsprechend noch buggy war.
Also das war zu dem Zeitpunkt ein Riesenproblem, weil wir haben da optimiert, was ging auf unserer Seite und sind da irgendwie bei ein, zwei Megabyte so an Live-Ding gekommen. Das Problem war aber, dass so einmal Foto machen, was ja bei unserer App relativ wichtig war, mal schnell so 32 Megabyte RAM gefressen hat. Und der hat nicht schnell genug wieder weg war, dass er da teilweise beim Foto machen bei dem API-Call von Apple selber so viel Speicher angefallen ist, dass er abgeschossen wurde. Das haben sie inzwischen gefixt. Also so viel von den Apple eigenen API-Calls haben zu dem Zeitpunkt noch so viel Speicher gefressen, dass deine restliche App so nahezu nichts brauchen durfte. Sonst hat es Boom gemacht.
Und hat er sozusagen gar keine Chance.
Genau. Das war wirklich das, was am nervigsten war an der Stelle. Also das war das anstrengendste ist inzwischen, aber dahingehend eigentlich alles gefixt, verhält sich nicht mehr so. Trotzdem, wenn man eine App macht, die ein bisschen mehr Speicher braucht, ist es schon ein grundsätzliches Designproblem, das man bedenken muss. Das heißt, man muss eigentlich jederzeit gerne Zeug cashen, weil das ist schneller. Man hat ja nicht die schnellste Plattform von allen, aber man muss den Cash für die Dinge, die man macht, so bauen, dass wenn das Betriebssystem vorbeikommt und sagt, hey, mach mal frei, dass man den auch schnell frei machen kann. Und das war halt teilweise auch ein bisschen anstrengend. Das hieß für mich in der Ecke, ich habe Objekte aus dem SQL-Sachen gemacht und zum Beispiel auch von den Bildern, die da drinstecken. Und dann habe ich halt, wenn das Betriebssystem vorbeikommt und sagt, ich brauche Speicher, mal alle praktisch Nutztaten weggeschmissen und nur noch die ID gehabt und eben danach das wieder zurückladen müssen. Und dafür gibt es keine allgemeine API eben wie CoreData, dass du das einfach so transparent machst, sondern das musst du ja bei Hand machen und da gibt es viele Fälle zu bedenken und man darf Zeug nicht wegnehmen, wenn es gerade irgendwo in der Anzeige ist und und und. Spannende Geschichte, anstrengend aber auch.
Wenn man jetzt hier nochmal diese Kategorien da hochholt, Productivity, Utility und Immersive. Tolle Kategorie. Das ist das, was dann Spiele sind.
Genau.
Beziehungsweise alles, was so...
Was meinst du denn damit?
Google Earth ist auch Immersive. Das heißt, du wirst reingezogen in das Ding.
Gar nichts mehr Vertrautes, sondern irgendwie das Ding...
Du machst eh was komplett Eigenes...
.drückt sich irgendwie. Ist halt mit nichts anderem was zu tun.
Also die wesentliche Unterschiede zwischen Utility und Immersive ist wohl, Utility zeigt dir so einen Bildschirm an mit Informationen. Du hast so einen Controls, die du kennst. Das ist halt so eine App, die halt...
Das Telefon wird so ein Messgerät sozusagen.
Richtig, ja. Irgendwie Börsenkurse und so. Das ist da so der Standardanwendungsfall. Und Immersive ist halt wirklich in der Hauptsache Spiele, aber halt auch so Sachen wie der Dicom, X-Ray, was heißt X-Ray auf Deutsch? Röntgen, Bild, Anzeige, Viewer, oder wie du sagst, Google Earth, so Kram.
Ja, ich bin ja nicht ganz unschuldig da dran, dass ich euch dann auch mal in diesen immersiven Bereich getrieben habe. Nicht wahr? Kleiner Disclaimer. Wir waren gemeinsam unterwegs dieses Jahr in Toronto und haben das Projekt Blinkenlides gemacht. Ihr beide wart ja mit im Team und wart auch sehr fleißig da in der Macintosh- und in der iPhone-Programmierung unterwegs und habt diesen schicken Simulator gemacht für das Projekt, also quasi live eine Visualisierung dessen, was quasi auf dem Haus, auf dem Kunstwerk dort ablief. Wir haben ja da wieder ein Haus umgebaut in Bildschirme. Und ja, das war ja dann aber auch Neuland, weil das hatte ja dann mit Productivity nicht mehr so viel zu tun, mehr so mit Produktivitätsverdichtung. Was für Herausforderungen habt ihr denn sozusagen an der Stelle?
Also erstmal war es natürlich eine Umstellung, wenn man zumindest schon so ein bisschen OpenGL kennt, mehr so oldschool OpenGL, sich mal da reinzufuchsen, wie funktioniert das dann jetzt mit OpenGL ES?
ES ist so die Light Version? Genau, Embedded Systems.
Ja, und da haben sie halt auch gesagt, so jetzt schneiden wir die alten Zöpfe ab und bitte hier mal den neuen Syntax verwenden und irgendwie GL Start und GL Beginn und GL End könnt ihr jetzt mal gleich vergessen. Und jetzt bitte mal hier so. Und da muss man sich dann natürlich schon ein bisschen umstellen und gucken, so die Spezifikationen nebeneinander halten, gucken, was ging denn früher so und wie geht das denn jetzt? Und dann mit dem iPhone natürlich noch mal unter dem Aspekt, was ist denn auf dem iPhone performant davon tatsächlich?
Vielleicht kurz zur OpenGL. Also diese ES ist eine Spezifikation für Embedded Systems, also für Systeme, die jetzt nicht so die volle 3D-Brachial-Power mit sich bringen, wie man das so normalerweise gewohnt ist. Aber alles, was in der ES geht, geht auch in dem aktuellen OpenGL. Es ist nur so, dass ein paar alte Ansätze, die mal früher galten und die heute so kompatibilitätsmäßig beim richtigen OpenGL noch mitgeschleppt werden, da schon ausgestorben sind. Das heißt, der OpenGL ES kann auch das Wissen eins zu eins auf eine richtige OpenGL Installation übernehmen?
Mehr oder weniger, ja. Ja, und dann gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt war es halt auch noch, war ja dann auch, wo war das jetzt auch schon gar nicht so lange her. Nee, blödsinn.
Es ist nicht so lange her.
Na, es ist halt grundsätzlich noch so eine Geschichte, so die Erfahrungswerte, was performt auf dem iPhone, was muss ich machen, dass ich da schnelle 3D-Performance bekomme, was gibt es zu beachten? Da gibt es noch nicht so viel, erstens nicht so viele offizielle Doku. Also, muss man ganz klar sagen. Und auch nicht Erfahrungswerte bei vielen Leuten, denke ich. Das ist ja selbst Nemco, die jetzt irgendwie Katamari geportiert haben fürs iPhone, hatten in der ersten Version schon massiv Performance-Probleme, was die Frame Rate anging. Und da kam jetzt irgendwie heute die neue Version raus und die rennt dann ein bisschen schneller. Ich würde vermuten, da hat Apple irgendwie so das OpenGL ES Emergency-Team hingeschickt und hat denen das mal irgendwie neu gekodet. Aber ja, man muss da gucken und man muss sich da auch wirklich auf eine Ebene begeben, wo man dann die Dokus von Imagine Tech liest, die den 3D-Chip machen für das Vieh. Power VR ist es, glaube ich, Power VR FX und FX ist, glaube ich, der Chip, richtig. Und da eben Dokus lesen und das SDK von denen angucken, was es dann aber nur für Windows gibt zurzeit.
Wie nur für Windows?
Frag mich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Meist, wenn man 3D fürs iPhone entwickeln will, dann hat man nicht mehr die freie Plattform wahr?
Nee, das SDK, das da dabei ist, das halt so tolle Texturen macht für den Chip und das leuchtet für Windows.
Also es gibt halt ein, in Anführungszeichen, cooleres SDK für eben diesen Chip mit noch mehr Utilities, gerade was Texturen und Export aus 3D-Programmen angeht und irgendwie Vertex-Optimization und so Kram, dass das eben ordentlich da in dem Chip drin landet und performant ist dann auch. Die Tools gibt es halt momentan tatsächlich nur für Windows mit diesem SDK. Also ich habe da, man liest so im Netz in Mailing-Listen, dass irgendwie da wohl Apple noch irgendwelche komischen Bedenken in Sachen NDA hätte und dass die Imagine-Tech-Jungs eigentlich gerne schon auch das Zeug für OS X rausbringen würden, aber ob das stimmt oder nicht, ich weiß es nicht. Es ist auf jeden Fall so, wenn du wirklich performante 3D-Grafik haben willst, bist du zurzeit ganz gut beraten, dir so einiges auch auf Windows anzugucken.
Das heißt, das hast du dann auch gemacht und hast die Software dann unter Windows entwickelt oder was?
Oder hast du das angeschaut? Ich habe erstmal die Dokus von denen gelesen, das geht ja auch ohne Windows, und dann habe ich so angefangen, da ein bisschen rumzukoden und 3D-Engine zu basteln rudimentär, habe das auch soweit ganz nett hinbekommen, dass es performt, nur irgendwie, ja, ich habe gemerkt, da kann man durchaus einiges an Zeit noch reinstecken, dass es rund wird. Und dann habe ich zu dem Zeitpunkt gesehen, oh, da gibt es jemanden, der hat schon einiges an Zeit investiert und der hat auch richtig viel Ahnung im Gegensatz zu mir, nämlich der arbeitet irgendwie für Rockstar und hat irgendwie an GTA 4 mitgeschraubt und der schmeißt hier unter BSD-Lizenzen eine 3D-Engine ins Netz für das iPhone.
Wie heißt die?
Die heißt Oolong, wie der T.
Wie der T mit Doppel O.
Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, das probierst du doch jetzt mal aus. Jetzt wo du so ein bisschen Ahnung hast, kannst du da vielleicht auch tatsächlich auf einer Ebene einsteigen, wo du dann relativ fix sinnvolle Dinge tun kannst mit dem Vieh. Hab dann eben geguckt, die Jungs von, also der Junge von O'Long, der hat auch schon ganz fein die offiziellen Beispiele, die es eben bis jetzt nur für Windows gab, von diesem Imagine-Tech SDK, auch portiert, dass es unter seiner Engine direkt läuft, sprich kann er dann auch von dem Mac OS X ganz fein erstmal angucken, was kann ich denn mit dem Vieh machen und was ist hier so ein Simple Code dabei. Und ja, habe mich dann auf der Ebene da rein gefuchst und dann eine Pipeline gebastelt, mit der wir unser 3D-Modell dann tatsächlich irgendwie aus dem Konvolut von 3D-Programmen, mit dem das entstanden ist, so in ein Format kriegen, dass dann auch das iPhone irgendwie verschrieht. Das ist dieses Imagine Tech, ich weiß das gar nicht mehr, P, irgendwas mit P, also PVLT ist das Texturenformat und...
Ich glaube, hier ist auch noch mal eine Sendung über 3D-Programme, Datenformate nötig, bis ich habe immer das Gefühl, wen auch immer man da fragt, bericht dann nervlich zusammen. Also wenn man sich so mit den... Das bin ich glaube ich auch, ja. Die Diskussion mit den Leuten, die sich mit dem 3D-Teil beschäftigt haben, das ist also auch wirklich jedes Mal, wenn es wieder um ein neues Ding geht, immer so ein totales Drama.
Also was mich da wirklich total verwirrt hat, war eigentlich, dass wir so eine Textur auf der Auflösungsgröße fürs iPhone, wo wir es gebraucht haben, wirklich, der ein halbes Tag so ein dicker Rechen einen halben Tag lang backen musste. Es gibt so ein Prozess, der heißt, Texturen backen und im Endeffekt ist es schon ein vorbeleuchteter Textur-Schnipsel, so in eine große OpenGL-Textur zu packen, dass man praktisch möglichst wenig Kontextwechsel dann beim Darstellen hat, weil dann kann man immer wieder alle Polygone, die man hat, auf dieser Textur arbeiten und die nehmen halt den Ausschnitt, wo ihr kleiner Fetzelchen drin ist. Also diese Texturen sehen wild aus und die zu erstellen dauert wohl echt lange noch. Also das hat mich sehr überrascht.
Da ist also ordentlich Gear in Bewegung gebracht worden und diese paar Pixel, wie viel sind es beim iPhone? 480 x 23?
420, ja.
Um für diesen kleinen Bildschirm da irgendwie 3D zu machen. Aber dann, das Ergebnis konnte sich ja sehen lassen, wie ich fand, also das war extrem flüssig in der Bewegung.
Wir haben so im Endeffekt 24 Frames hinbekommen. Das war unsere Zielframe-Rate da und die sieht sehr flüssig aus dann noch. Ja, da waren wir sehr stolz auch.
Kann man ja immer noch gucken, ist ja immer noch flüssig.
Ist immer noch flüssig. Wir sind sogar in diesem Wohnzimmer, wo einer der Streams seinen Ursprung hat, so als Backup, falls die anderen mal abstürzen.
Ach ja, stimmt ja.
Ja, also man kann so die Replays nach wie vor gucken von dem Gebäude.
Genau, also wenn es interessiert, die Stereoscope-Applikation, die ist ja noch vorhanden und läuft auch weiter, also wird auch nach wie vor mit Daten live versorgt. Es gibt nicht mehr das passende Haus dazu, aber die Simulation dessen bleibt sozusagen erhalten. Jetzt, gut, ich meine, es ist immer schwierig in so einem Podcast, wenn man jetzt über Entwicklungen redet. Man kann jetzt nicht irgendwie anfangen, jede Manual-Page vorzulesen, das ist ja sicherlich auch nicht das Ziel. Was ich eigentlich mal so ein bisschen hinbekommen wollte, ist einen Einblick dafür zu kriegen, wie Entwicklung jetzt sozusagen für das iPhone sich vor allem unterscheidet vom Desktop. Was habt ihr denn so für Tipps parat für Entwickler, die jetzt auch Interesse haben, fürs iPhone zu entwickeln? Nachfrage ist ja durchaus da. Wie man da jetzt am besten vorgehen sollte. Vielleicht auch nochmal den offiziell notwendigen Marsch durch die Institution Apple, den man da machen muss, auch nochmal mit reinwerfen.
Um mal ganz vorne anzufangen, wenn man noch nicht C kann, sollte man erstmal C lernen und wenn man noch nicht Objective-C kann, sollte man danach Objective-C lernen. Dann ist man schon mal ganz gut von den Grundvoraussetzungen drin. Ich denke, man kann eigentlich auch mit dem iPhone direkt anfangen, den Erstkontakt mit Coco zu knüpfen. Man muss jetzt nicht erstmal für einen Mac irgendwie da was geschraubt haben. Was meinst du?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Man muss auf alle Fälle mal so, ich denke, mit Objective-C erstmal den Kontakt über Xcode und über die Entwickler-Tools mal zu schaffen und dann kann man durchaus auch gleich anfangen, diesen Gegenden-Simulator zu programmieren. Das ist durchaus okay. Es ist zwar noch eigenartiger als jetzt ein Desktop, weil natürlich die Umgebung auch eine ganz andere ist und die Konzepte, die jetzt controllermäßig dahinterstehen, muss man jetzt erstmal verstehen. Aber es ist, glaube ich, durchaus auch okay, da direkt anzufangen. Ich finde, Desktop haben halt ein gutes Buch immer als Empfehlung, aber fürs iPhone selber noch nicht, glaube ich.
Nee, aber ich denke, das Buch ist trotzdem nach wie vor eine Empfehlung. Aaron Hilligast haben wir auch schon im letzten Podcast empfohlen.
Das ist ja eh davon auszugehen, dass da jetzt noch mehr Bücher rauskommen werden.
Ja, es kommt da sicherlich noch einiges an iPhone-spezifischen Titeln, aber was jetzt davon gut ist und was nicht, da sind wir wohl am wenigsten dran.
Aber wir sprechen von iPhone-Entwicklern, die brauchen eine Mac. Man kann das nicht auf Windows machen, obwohl das iPhone mehr oder weniger ein Cross-Plattform-Gerät in der Benutzung ist. Zumindest kenne ich einige Windows-Junger, die durchaus ein iPhone haben. Wenn man dafür entwickeln will, braucht man eine Mac.
Weil man verwendet Xcode, also die selbe Umgebung, die man auch verwendet, um für eine Mac zu...
Man braucht auch eine Intel-Mac. Also es langt nicht, so einen alten G5i Mac vom Vater abzustauben oder so, oder halt einen gebrauchten Intel-Mac. Aber Intel muss sein, sonst ist nicht. Dann braucht man einen Online-Account, glaube ich.
Oder? Ja, also ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen, man kann mit dem, was man so, wenn man dann eine Intel-Mac hat und was man dann dazu umsonst noch bekommt, kann man schon sehr gut einsteigen und schon sehr weit kommen. Also allein gegen den Simulator zu programmieren, ist jetzt auf jeden Fall, gerade für jemanden, der neu ist, sicherlich ein sehr guter Einstieg in die Materie. Und man muss jetzt nicht gleich diese 100 Dollar Richtung Apple werfen, um überhaupt für sich einschätzen zu können, macht mir das überhaupt Spaß, will ich das überhaupt tun, bin ich hier zu Hause.
Aber man muss schon dieses iPhone SDK runterladen und installieren.
Das kostet ja nichts.
Ja, aber das kostet ja nichts. Du musst sagen, als Entwickler registrieren, aber das ist soweit erstmal kostenlos.
Genau. Erstmal als Online-Entwickler muss ich registrieren, ob das geht. Genau.
Und wenn man dann tatsächlich will, dass da der Code auch auf dem Telefon läuft, dann muss man diese 100 Dollar tatsächlich werfen?
Genau. Und die sollte man aber auch schon dann werfen, wenn man …Die sind pro Jahr. Die sind pro Jahr. Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man ein Programm veröffentlichen will, weil das Telefon verhält sich anders wie der Simulator. Und ohne diese 100 Dollar kann man das nicht auf dem iPhone installieren, weil da muss alles gesigned sein, was läuft. Also auch auf meinem Entwickler-iPhone muss jetzt temporär zumindest die App, die ich da über Xcode draufschmeiße, mit einem Schlüssel verschlüsselt werden, damit das alles funktioniert.
Ich denke auch, wenn man jetzt drüber nachdenkt, OpenGL zum Beispiel zu entwickeln, da hilft einem der Simulator halt nicht so wahnsinnig weiter, wenn es darum geht, die Performance zu beurteilen. Weil der läuft ja so schnell wie er läuft. Da kann man jetzt Glück haben und das ist so in etwa die Geschwindigkeit, die man auch auf dem Phone hat, aber eher unwahrscheinlich.
Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, der Simulator läuft wirklich in dem Host OS. Das heißt, der Simulator läuft auf Mac OS X. Das heißt, die Foundation, die er benutzt, ist tendenziell die Foundation, die auch auf dem Desktop läuft. Da kann man zum Beispiel Sachen machen, wie mit dem NS File Manager, irgendwie slash irgendwas ansurfen, was auf dem iPhone einfach nicht geht. Was aber hier so das Home Directory oder was ähnliches zurückgibt. Und alle diese Dinge kann man nur auf dem Telefon testen.
Auf dem Simulator blutet ab und zu so ein bisschen was vom Host OS rein.
Das heißt, man kann Dinge tun, die man nicht auf dem iPhone tun kann, aber ein Programm, was sozusagen auf dem iPhone das Richtige tut, sollte eigentlich auch im Simulator dasselbe tun.
Genau. Also ein Beispiel hier, ich habe mal spaßeshalber den Unterbau von Portmap da reingeworfen und wollte mal gucken, weil das wäre auch für so ein Portmap-Tool eigentlich ganz nett, wenn ich irgendwie...
Portmap ist euer frei verfügbare Library.
Für UPnP und NAT-Portmap. Und bei Körmer hat ein Feature davon ist halt auch anzugucken, was auf meinem aktuellen Router für Portmappings gesetzt sind für Dynamische und das hätte ich spannend gefunden und da fehlen hat einfach ein paar Netzwerk- Unterbaugeschichten auf Unix-Seite noch. Also muss man wissen, im Simulator lief das nämlich und dann auf dem iPhone wieder nicht.
Aber so eben zum Einsteigen, wie gesagt, Simulator ist eine gute Idee und wenn man dann tatsächlich sich dafür entscheidet, ich will da was auf das Telefon drauf haben, dann diese 100 Dollar bei ADC entwerten und dann kriegt man in einem relativ mittlerweile akzeptablen Zeitraum dann auch Post.
Ja, das dürfte relativ schnell gehen inzwischen.
So e-Post oder gibt es dann richtig Post?
Also du kriegst auf jeden Fall E-Mails. Das war zu unserem Zeitpunkt haben wir auch noch was per Post bekommen.
Ja, wir mussten uns auch noch als Firma irgendwie so sagen, dass wir Firma sind. Aber es war auch ein Firmen-Account. Man kann als Privatentwickler das machen oder als Firma. Und als Firma machen sie wohl so einen Background-Check über die dritte Firma.
Da ruft dann irgendwie so ein Dienstleister aus Prostitantien an und fragt dich so, ob du auch der bist, der behauptet, dass du bist. Und sollst du mal irgendwie irgendwas faxen, dass das belegt und so. Das ist dann sehr eins-null alles. Man muss mal vorsichtig zuvormitteln. Ja, aber wenn du das dann hinter dir hast, dann klappt das auch relativ fix mittlerweile, denke ich.
Ja, genau. Und dann entwickelst du so ein Ding und dann kannst du was Freies reinstellen, dann in diesen App-Store. Das ist ja der einzige Distributionsweg, den du offiziell wählen kannst. Wenn du allerdings jetzt auch was verkaufen willst, ich kann mal noch eine Hürde oben drauf, dann musst du entsprechend dich bei dem iTunes-App-Store so anmelden, dass der dir auch Geld geben kann. Du brauchst halt irgendeinen internationalen Zahlungsverkehr, Sachen eintragen, drei Verträge unterschreiben, irgendwie viermal beten oder so. Man kriegt dann wieder, das passiert online, über iTunes Connect, da kann man auf alle Fälle schon mal einen Account anlegen, sobald man in einem anderen Programm drin ist. Aber dann muss man da noch mal den Vertrag wirklich unterschreiben und faxen oder per Post schicken, um dann wirklich auch Geld dafür zu sehen, für das, was man da einstellt.
Vielleicht noch ein Tipp für alle, die jetzt denken, ich mache jetzt eine kleine Firma und mach das alles und verkaufe meine Software über iTunes. In diesem Vertrag, den man dann mit iTunes abschließt, da braucht man eine Text-Identification-Number. Oder braucht man die nicht mehr?
Das ist offiziellerweise wohl nicht mehr so. Die Information war damals schon nicht wirklich so, aber die haben wir nicht rausprügeln können aus den Apple-Leuten. Also man braucht angeblicherweise eine amerikanische Steuernummer, und zwar eine bestimmte. Und wir haben uns die besorgt. Sehr spektakulär.
Na ja, du brauchst halt eine TIN, und diese TIN, das wäre jetzt der Tipp gewesen, der offensichtlich obsolet ist, aber vielleicht braucht es hier jemand anderes zufällig, deswegen ist es trotzdem erwähnt. Da ruft man bei einer irgendwie, ich wo war es, Indiana, oder irgendwo, man ruft irgendwo bei einer speziellen Steuerbehörde an, und dann geht das alles schön per Telefon, und die nette Dame am anderen Ende fragt dich dann irgendwie so ein paar komische Fragen, und zum Schluss sagt sie dir dann eine Nummer, und dann hast du eine Text-Identification-Namme. Also das geht alles ohne Geld und sehr schnell. Das wollte ich nur gesagt haben, falls du es immer machen willst.
Aber das war jetzt so vielen Leuten viel zu kompliziert, dass sie das haben fallen lassen.
Ich glaube, sie haben es wirklich nie offiziell gebraucht, aber sie wussten es nicht. Also Legal war halt hinten dran.
Ja, da gibt es ein paar so Sachen. Also zum Beispiel auch für Europa musste man extra Rechnungen stellen noch mal, damit sie einem das Geld überwiesen haben eine Zeit lang, bis sie dann gemerkt haben, dass es das auch nicht braucht. Aber sie sind sich da auch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, wie das mit diesen Steuern und dem ganzen Geld so funktioniert hat.
Tja, ich meine, bisher hatten sie nur so zwei, drei Musiklabels, denen sie da ab und zu mal Geld überweisen. Jetzt haben sie es mit einer Myriade an Unternehmen zu tun. Da haben sie wahrscheinlich auch erst mal was gelernt.
Und man braucht ja gegen ein iPhone. Und zwar ein iPhone am besten, das nicht das tägliche Einsatz-iPhone ist.
Okay, gut. Das ist jetzt so der technokratische Prozess. Aber jetzt für die eigentliche Herangehensweise an die Entwicklung. Habt ihr da noch irgendwas, was ihr mit auf den Weg geben könnt?
Ich weiß nicht, also einfach machen, oder? Also keine Angst haben, mal ausprobieren und zu versuchen, sich irgendwie in dieses Gefüge reinzudenken, wie so Zeug auf dem iPhone funktioniert. Also ich denke, wenn man wirklich darauf Wert legt, da nicht ganz unten verloren zu gehen im iTunes-Store, dann muss man sich vor allem viel Gedanken machen über, wie bringe ich meine Idee so auf das iPhone, dass es aussieht wie eine iPhone-App?
Ja, also für mich gibt es mehrere Ebenen, die eine ist so, wenn du eine schöne iPhone-App machen willst, dann mach schönes Paper Prototyping vorher, komplett den Workflow, jeden Screen einzeln aufzeichnen, dass es funktioniert. Da brauchst du noch keinen Schritt programmieren. Wir haben es sehr weit so gemacht. Ich habe so einen Notizblock, wo eigentlich alle Schritte wirklich mal...
Man sollte sich so einen Notizblock besorgen, der so iPhone-Screen-Größe hat.
Genau.
Da kann man sich irgendwie, wenn man da Wert drauf legt, auch im Internet so Templates runterladen, ausdrucken und dann da reinmalen. Ich meine, so genau geht es ja auch nicht.
Aber auf alle Fälle...
So ein Käs-Fiel-Papier kriegen die meisten irgendwie noch aufs Papier, halbwegs in den Relationen, die so...
Ich denke mir, so ein Dinner-Sieben-Abreiß-Block oder so ist vielleicht gar keine schlechte Idee.
Aber jeden Screen halt mal aufzeichnen, den kompletten Workflow von jeder Aktion, die man da machen will.
Weil...
Also einerseits, man vergisst wahnsinnig viele Dinge. Also wenn man das nicht macht, dann ist man beim Programmieren an der Stelle, oh, mache ich das jetzt so oder so? Und das ist zu spät. Wenn man das da macht, dann muss man vielleicht den kompletten Workflow noch mal umdenken und erstens man entdeckt viele Dinge schon im Vorfeld. Die Applikationen auf dem iPhone sind tendenziell so einfach, dass das auch wirklich geht. Also auf einer Desktop-Applikation, das habe ich selber, da könnte man nicht Paper Prototypen. Da kommen zu viele Dinge gleichzeitig, verschiedene Syntax-Modi, andere Farben, wie auch immer. Eine iPhone-App ist grundsätzlich einfach.
Eure Software, die ihr auf dem Mac habt.
Genau. Also es ist so einfach, dass es geht. Und es ist am wenigsten Zeitverschwendung, wenn man nochmal andere Ideen hat.
Ich finde es halt grundsätzlich ein guter Prozess, um sich den Workflow zu visualisieren. Storyboarding in Anführungszeichen zu sehen. Was passiert, wenn, was, wie ist die Abfolge der Dinge, wie ist die Kausalität des Interfaces.
Ich finde es auch ein idealer Ort, um Zeuge aufzuschreiben. Wenn man in dem Screen ist und dann muss man zum ersten Mal den wirklichen Eintrag in dieser Tabelle malen. Ist es dann ein Bild links, ist es ein Bild rechts, ist der Text links oben und so weiter. Diese ganzen Fragen stellt man sich beim Malen, weil man muss ja auch malen, sonst geht es ja nicht. Die sind schon mal sehr wertvoll.
Das ist halt nichts, was man so on the fly beim Programmieren entscheiden sollte.
Sollte, aber was oft passiert. Ich mache es halt irgendwo hin und dann ändere ich es noch.
Und dann änderst du es nicht?
Genau, dann ändere ich es nicht. Oder dann habe ich eine technische Hürde, die mir das verhindert. Und ich habe nicht den Schweinehund, das trotzdem zu machen, weil es viel mehr Aufwand hat. Und zum anderen habe ich jetzt mit diesen Screens ideale Notizmöglichkeiten. Ich kann aufschreiben, das Bild sollte mindestens so groß sein. Die Sortierung ist in der Reihenfolge oder in der Reihenfolge.
Der Knopf muss rot sein, weil er was Destruktives macht.
Genau. Also das kann ich nur empfehlen. Das ist eine gigantische Hilfe. Wenn man an der Stelle sich mit der Applikation dann im Reinen ist und sie dann unterprogrammiert, dann ist der letzte Teil wirklich easy.
Mir fällt gerade ein, dass es, glaube ich, beim vorletzten Kongress, beim 23 oder 24C3, gab es auch einen Vortrag zu Paper Prototyping. War das letztes Jahr oder war das vorletztes Jahr?
Ich habe ihn nicht so oft gefragt.
Ich war nicht drin, glaube ich.
Nein, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen.
Ist aber auf jeden Fall auf Chaosradio auch archiviert. Kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal... Oder ist er aufgezeichnet worden? Ja, ich glaube schon.
Ich dachte, es gäbe den ja.
Ich glaube auch, ja.
Das war so die eine Ebene. Die andere ist, wenn man eine Immersive-App macht, dann sind alle Wege offen. Da muss man sich überlegen, was man macht. Im Endeffekt kriegt man Touches, die das Ding bedient. Aber ansonsten hat man eine 3D-Canvas, auf die man malen kann. Das ist ganz kreativ. Da funktionieren keine Screens großartig.
Da muss man sich auch Gedanken machen, was funktioniert. Man sieht ja jetzt auch schon einiges an verschiedenen Steuerungsmöglichkeiten. Gerade wenn man sich anguckt, was an Spielen so passiert im Store. Wie sich First-Person-Shooter da jetzt steuern. Oder wie da die Beschleunigungs-Sensoren genutzt werden. Das sind alles Sachen, die muss man sich mal durchdenken. Und relativ früh entscheiden, wie will ich denn interagieren? Wie will ich die Interaktion da lösen? Weil das ist auch was, was unter Umständen das Interface schon komplett beeinflusst.
Da würde ich den komplett anderen Weg einschlagen. Da würde ich möglichst schnell Prototypen bauen, die auf dem Phone selber laufen, bei der Immersive-Ecke. Ganz im Gegensatz zu der Productivity-Ecke. Ob es greift.
Kontrollierbarkeit, dementsprechend, was man so haben will.
Und der letzte ist eigentlich der finanzielle Aspekt. Mit was kann ich jetzt reich werden? Was ja vielleicht auch manche sich Gedanken mit im Sinn haben. Also mein Blick auf den Markt zieht da mehrere Dinge. Der eine Weg ist ganz, ganz kleines, super billiges 99 Cent Utility, was irgendwie viele Leute brauchen. Was nicht viel Investitionsaufwand ist, nämlich vielleicht eine Woche oder so zwei zu programmieren. Dann reinstellen und dann trägt sich das mit der Zeit, wenn das irgendwer findet. Das ist so ein Weg, der relativ häufig gewählt wird, den ich nachvollziehen kann. Eine andere Ecke ist so, diese High-Profile......
99 Dollar-Applikationen zu schreiben. Da braucht man dann nur einmal zu verkaufen.
Da hat die Kohle wieder drin. Hat schon mal einer probiert. Ich meinte mehr so diese High-Profile-Ecke, wo jetzt Classics und so weiter reinkommt. Also die Ecke oder Tap-Tap-Revolution, wie heißt das?
Oder Ocarina oder diese ganzen Sachen, die halt so die Mac-Presse dann geistern.
Das einfach so viel Aufmerksamkeit zieht am Anfang, dass ich es dadurch schon trägt. Was auch immer das sein mag, das ist durch Polish, durch...
Das war jetzt mal ja vorher nicht.
Eben, das ist so eine Empfehlung, film doch mal einen Blockbuster.
Ich weiß es nicht. So was wie Classics ist zum Beispiel einfach so eine Wahnsinn. Diese Polish-Ecke zieht auf Mac wahnsinnig. Also wenn du so wie Delicious Library von der Optik so ein Ding machst, das gucken einfach viele Leute an.
Das ist, glaube ich, grundsätzlich eine Geschichte. Also man sollte da, wenn man da wirklich jetzt in Anführungszeichen ernsthaft da entwickeln will und also das jetzt nicht zum Spaß macht, was ich natürlich auch immer gerne mache und da irgendwie. Ja, aber wenn du halt sagst so hier, ich stecke hier Geld rein und es muss hinten irgendwie auch Geld rauskommen, weil ich möchte gern irgendwie, dass es sich so, ich mache das nicht irgendwie aus Spaß und der Freude, dann muss man sich auch noch darüber nachdenken, was man selbst kann und was andere besser können. Und wenn man selbst halt jetzt nicht der super Designer ist, klar gibt es auch Programmierer, die sehr gut designen, aber wenn man grafisch jetzt nicht so topfit ist, dann sucht man sich jemanden. Also da gibt es durchaus einige Dienstleister, die sich da auch auf Mac und iPhone spezialisieren. Und da kann man dann irgendwie sagen, ich brauche einen Icon, das gut aussieht, und dann kriegt man eins. Und das macht ja auch schon viel aus.
Ja, hübsch soll es sein. Liebe zum Detail. Was gibt es denn, wenn ich jetzt nochmal zurückkomme, zum Beispiel zu diesem Erlebnis, was ich mit diesem OpenMoco hatte, wo ich mir irgendwie das User-Interface angeschaut habe, wenn er das nicht erinnert, wird das nichts. Was sind denn so die Lehren, die ihr so jetzt gezogen habt aus der Anwendung und auch der Programmierung des iPhones, die andere Hersteller, die jetzt mit dem iPhone konkurrieren wollen? Weil, ich meine, so oder so, wir werden einfach neue, es werden einfach neue Devices kommen. Ich meine, jetzt ist Google da mit Android, das ist so ein Stück weit offen, ja. Also es ist nicht als ausgelieferte Plattform, jetzt nicht spürbar offener als das iPhone. Also nicht wirklich. Aber der Source Code ist ja da. Theoretisch könnten jetzt Leute hergehen und sich Android schnappen und daraus irgendwie was Neues bauen, was wahrscheinlich sogar nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich ist, dass irgendwie so was Ähnliches passieren wird. Aber es gibt immerhin noch die Initiativen wie OpenMoco und andere mögen vielleicht noch nachziehen. Was sind sozusagen jetzt die Lehren, die ihr gezogen habt aus dem Erlebnis iPhone-Entwicklung und auch Benutzung, die man dort vielleicht zur Anwendung bringen sollte, die quasi eine gute Idee sind?
Ja, es ist natürlich ein bisschen so, jeder ist gerne Nationaltrainer. Jeder weiß es besser.
Klar, jetzt bist du der Nationaltrainer.
Richtig. Was ich denke, was Apple sehr richtig gemacht hat mit dem iPhone und was alle anderen, z.B. die großen anderen Mobilfunkhersteller, nicht richtig machen oder sich selbst das Leben schwerer machen, damit ist, so eine Gerätebaseline zu haben und zu sagen, so, hier dieses Telefon, das sieht so aus, das hat folgende Features. Und hat so ein gewisses CPU-Level, auf dem man bauen kann und hat so und so viel Speicher. Und du programmierst das genau für dieses Ding. Du hast jetzt irgendwie da nicht einen Touchscreen oder keinen und irgendwie CPU oder fast keine und Speicher oder fast keinen. Sondern du kannst wirklich von dieser Baseline ausgehen und du kannst sagen, wenn das hier läuft, dann läuft das überall auf der ganzen Plattform so, wie es hier läuft. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine wesentliche Geschichte, gerade für die Third-Party-Entwickler, dass man da dann tatsächlich auch Dinge nutzt, die man nutzen kann. Ich habe das Gefühl, gerade bei Android habe ich auch Gedenken dahingehend, weil da gibt es halt keine klare Gerätebaseline. Da sagen so alles optional und ja, kann auch Touchscreen, aber muss nicht. Und dann weißt du halt als Entwickler immer nicht, soll ich jetzt diesen Aufwand betreiben und wirklich für jeden Einzelfall da ein extra Code pass einbauen, dass das auch funktioniert. Oder mache ich halt an manchen Stellen irgendwie Abstriche und sage, ich progere mir für den Kleinstgemeinsamen Nenner.
Okay, aber das ist ja mehr jetzt die Gerätepolitik, das bezieht sich ja mehr auf die Hersteller und Anbieter.
Es ist aber schon auch eine Plattformfrage. Also so eine homogene Plattform zu haben, glaube ich schon auch.
Okay, gut, aber es lässt sich... Gut, ich dachte jetzt gerade, aber im Hinblick, wenn man jetzt mal sagt, Open-Source-Entwicklung, also es ist ja offensichtlich, dass auch ein iPhone nicht alle Bedürfnisse abdecken können wird. Also allein schon, weil es eben eine geschlossene Plattform ist, das macht sicherlich für die Plattform als solche, so mit dem Store und den ganzen Kram und auch aus Sicherheitsaspekten ein Stück weit Sinn, ist aber natürlich dann eben auch für bestimmte Sachen einfach bekloppt. Und von daher wäre eben jetzt die Frage, was das User-Interfere ist, betrifft. Also das Design der Anwendung und wie man sozusagen Anwendung schreibt und schreiben muss. Was ist sozusagen da das Wertvollste? Was sagt der Nationaltrainer dazu?
Ja, der Nationaltrainer, der wahrscheinlich eine böse Post bekommt, denkt, dass da sehr ähnliches Problem wie auf dem Desktop auch verbreitet ist. Nämlich, dass man erst mal Software entwickelt und dann irgendwie Spray-on-Usability haben möchte. Also nach dem Motto, wir schreiben jetzt mal die Software und dann setzen wir den Usability-Designer dran und der macht das dann gut.
Der macht das dann, dass man das auch benutzen kann.
Genau, und darum funktioniert es halt nicht. Also das klappt in den allerwenigsten Fällen gut. Und da eben diesen Prozess umzukehren und von der anderen Seite zu kommen und zu sagen, so, hier, die Software muss Folgendes können und wie können wir die so bauen, dass es sinnvoll, einfach und dass es Spaß macht? Und das kannst du halt hinterher nicht mehr draufschrauben, wenn du schon eine Code-Basis hast und wenn du schon ein Interface hast. Weil es unter Umständen, wie Dominik vorher schon meinte, dazu führt, dass du irgendwie alles nochmal anders machen musst und dann machst du es nicht, weil du hast ja diese Arbeit schon investiert. Und diesen Entwicklungsprozess dahingehend stärker auf Usability und Design zu betonen und dann erst tatsächlich zu implementieren, das ist etwas, was sowohl für kleine als auch für große Plattformen, glaube ich, viel Nutzen bringt in jeglicher Entwicklung, sei es jetzt Open Source oder nicht.
Und auch gar nicht mal jetzt nur für mobile Geräte. Das ist ja eine generelle Aussage über Entwicklung. Und was jetzt das konkrete mobile User-Interface betrifft?
Also beim konkreten mobilen User-Interface denke ich mir so, bitte schneide es doch auf die Bedürfnisse des mobilen Benutzers zu. Also diese Geschichte, die Apple gemacht hat, wirklich in jeder App alles, was sie nicht unbedingt brauchen, einfach mal wegzulassen. Das ist gut. Also die Suche in Mail ist das Einzige, was mich nach wie vor ärgert, dass es nicht drin ist. Aber ansonsten, das ist einfach so die Essenz von diesem Ding, was ich mobil brauche. Es ist nicht der Ersatz für mein Mail zu Hause, sondern es ist mein mobiles Mail. Das hat andere Anforderungen. Da kann ich Zeug wegstreichen. Und alles, was ich da am Bedien-Hölle wegstreiche, schafft ein strafferes Erlebnis bei der Bedienung. Und ist halt einfach gut. Die Ecke, so was ich da bei anderen Handys immer sehe, was da an Bedien-Spektakeln abläuft, nur weil jedes Feature X und Y noch da drin ist im Mail-Client. Ich meine, das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen kontraproduktiv, jetzt diesen Plattformen das zu raten, weil ich meine, deshalb haben die ihre Leute, weil die können halt Feature X, was das iPhone nicht kann. Das ist im Moment ein bisschen schwierig. Also mein Empfinden ist, es ist eine gute Entscheidung, Zeug wegzulassen und vielleicht mehrere Programme dann zu machen, die dann weniger machen. Aber dann, aber Klarsinn in dem, was sie tun.
Das ist aber jetzt auch eigentlich eher wieder ein genereller Ansatz. Ich meine, aber auf jeden Fall ein guter Hinweis. Ich sage nur, was mich interessiert, ist dieses User-Interface, was einem sozusagen das iPhone zwingt zu machen. Also was du vorhin erwähnt hast, diese Drill-down-Geschichte zum Beispiel. Oder überhaupt, dass man in so Scheibchen, in so einzelnen Notizetteln denkt, die man dann irgendwie schön auf dem Küchentisch nebeneinander legen kann. Haltet ihr das für etwas, was sich alle abgucken sollten? Oder irgendwie so oder so werden? Ich meine, Apple hat seinerzeit ja mit seinem User-Interface quasi auch so die Vorlage für wie Maus und Fenster und Button und so weiter ist. Wird ihnen das jetzt an der Stelle wieder gelingen? Oder ist es das auch noch nicht so richtig?
Also finde ich interessanterweise gar nicht. Weil im iPhone ist es insgesamt dadurch, dass es konsistent ist und so gut gelöst. Aber wenn ich jetzt auf anderen Telefonen zum Beispiel nur die Idee nehmen würde, dass nur eine App aktiv ist und das andere, dass ich nicht mehr zurückkomme, da würde wahnsinnig viel verloren gehen. Also das funktioniert beim iPhone deswegen, weil das Gesamtkonstrukt genauso hindesignt wurde. Ich finde jetzt das generelle Konzept von dieser Drill-down und von der Ansicht und von genauso, finde ich jetzt nicht so spannend.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, also am Drill-down würde ich es jetzt auch nicht festmachen. Also dieses Konzept von wir präsentieren dir die Information, die du sehen willst, mit möglichst wenig Schnörkeln in einer Form, die du dich nicht übergeben möchtest. Das ist, glaube ich, schon was, was auch auf anderen Plattformen funktioniert. Also diese grundsätzliche Idee des Screen-Full, um wieder dieses schreckliche Wort zu benutzen, das ist, glaube ich, was, da können sich andere schon was abgucken von.
Eine andere Geschichte, ich meine, das iPhone, wenn da was geht, dann geht das flüssig. So eine Liste scrollen, das macht einfach zack. Das ist auch so ein... Performance. Aber Performance im Sinne von gefühlte Performance für einen Benutzer, dass der da hinkommt, wo er will. Das ist so was, was die anderen Plattformen gar nicht hinkriegen. Also meine Nokia-Telefone, die ich so hatte, die ein bisschen mehr konnten als so die ganz alten schwarz-weißen, die waren alle halt performanstechnisch so mit irgendwie, ich lade mal das Programm, ich lade mal das Programm, da kommt das Sand ne geladen.
Vor allem auch so Sanduhr und Ruckeln und so. Klar, das ist jetzt alles aus unserer Perspektive und was wir schlimm finden. Und es gibt Leute, die finden das alles gar nicht so wild. Aber das macht für mich schon einen wesentlichen Unterschied, dass ich bei meinem iPhone noch nie auf eine Sanduhr oder auf einem Beatball geguckt habe.
Das passt für mich auch in dieses Konzept rein von der Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, dass sie sagen, die Apps hier haben eine kurze Aufmerksamkeitsspanne. Ich warte kurz auf einen Bus, also gucke ich kurz etwas nach. Das muss schnell gehen, das muss dann da sein. Wenn es da nicht da ist, dann gucke ich es beim nächsten Mal gar nicht mehr nach, wenn der Bus schon auf dem Horizont ist. Ich nutze das mobile Gerät einfach anders. Und auf der Ebene könnten sich die anderen schon viel abschneiden.
Performance, 30 Frames pro Sekunde sozusagen.
Es geht ja nicht um messbare Performance, es geht um gefühlte Performance. Das ist ein wesentlicher Unterschied.
Ja klar, aber das spielt ja eine große Rolle damit. Diese Anforderung, die du jetzt sozusagen an das generelle User-Interface hast, das ist glaube ich das, was sich an Anforderungen an Spiele im Wesentlichen in den letzten Jahren durchgehend gehalten hat. Wer würde sonst First-Person-Shooter spielen, wenn der nur 5 Frames pro Sekunde macht? Man erwartet einfach, dass es flüssig ist, und zwar immer und nie nicht.
Aber es ist halt auch nur ein Teilaspekt. Eine technische Performance ist auch wichtig, aber auch das Gefühl zu haben, ich habe hier zweimal geklickt, und es ist das passiert, was ich wollte, und ich bin zufrieden. Ich muss mich da durchhangeln mit einem Joystick, durch die Gegend wurschteln und was auch immer tun. Das ging irgendwie jetzt bumm, bumm, bumm, auch wenn es vielleicht nicht wahnsinnig viel kürzer gedauert hat.
Aber kurze Wege, wenig Schritte, was du vor Eingangs schon erwähnt hast.
Und schnelle Reaktionen, also ich finde wirklich, das ist eine technische Grundlage, die das überhaupt erst möglich gemacht hat. Ich meine, wenn man das jetzt mal vergleicht mit der Geschichte, die sie mit Newton gemacht haben, was ja auch ein schönes Konzept war, aber so die Kerntechnologie von Newton hat halt nicht gescheit funktioniert. In der ersten Iteration, später ja viel besser. Aber wenn jetzt hier der Touch praktisch so zäh gewesen wäre alles, wenn selbe iPhone wie du jetzt hast, nur langsamer, weniger Frames, und ab und zu mal so das falsche Ding gedrückt dann, weil die Erkennung halt nicht gescheit funktioniert hat. Das wäre total ein Grab gewesen für dieses Telefon. Und da sind im Moment die anderen Handyhersteller. Also alle, die ich hier mit Touch und so weiter gesehen habe, langsam zäh. Ich bin dann da, ich scrolle, jetzt ist es drüber hinaus, ich muss wieder weg, es ist ein Ärgernis. Und das muss weg. Also das muss einfach so smooth sein, wie es hier Mac OS X ermöglicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das auf den anderen Plattformen, ob man das auch so leicht hinkriegt, weil es wurde hier schon von unten hochdesignt für genau diese Smoothness und für diese Performance. Aber das ist wirklich, wenn man so eine Bedienung haben will, die eigentlich ja sehr fehleranfällig ist, mal irgendwo hin drücken und was anderes erwischen. Das kennt man doch eigentlich von all diesen Touch-Geräten, von jeder universellen Fernbedienung, die ich hab, war schon mal irgendwie, von ihrem Bankautomaten, der hat ein, ja, Bankart. Und die haben genau geschafft, dass ich das verbinde ich überhaupt nicht mit meinem iPhone.
Ich denke, viel von dem, was man besser machen kann, findet tatsächlich auf einer Ebene statt, die gar nicht technisch oder implementationsmäßig ist, sondern wirklich eine, die viel mit Design und grundsätzlichen Gedanken zu tun hat. Ich mein, was das iPhone besser macht als andere Telefone für mich, ist halt formvolles Funktion. Und es macht es auch nicht an allen Ecken gut und macht es nicht perfekt, aber es macht viel eher das, was ich will. Ich bediene es so, wie ich will. Es ist mir nichts im Weg und es sieht trotzdem nicht scheiße aus dabei.
Also formvolles Funktion im Sinne von, das User-Interface leitet sich direkt von der Funktionalität ab, die man haben will?
Die Bedienung steht im Vordergrund und das Design kommt dann hinten dazu als unterstützendes Element für die Bedienung und nicht umgekehrt.
Ja, ich denke, das war jetzt doch ein ganz guter Durchmarsch hier durch die Aspekte. Fällt euch noch irgendwas Wichtiges ein, was wir hätten erwähnen müssen? Mir fällt nämlich jetzt gerade nichts mehr ein.
Ja, ihr könnt noch nicht jammern, wie schlecht alles ist, aber das muss man ja nicht.
Aber wie schlecht ist es denn?
Ja, also...
Du meinst jetzt diese Entwicklerperspektive, es könnte alles viel besser sein oder...
Es könnte noch viel stabiler sein und das Ganze signieren und die AM-Kram könnte irgendwie auch komplett weggelassen werden oder zumindest sinnvoll funktionieren für die Entwickler. Man kann sich viel wünschen, aber es ist halt auch mit allen Shortcomings, ich bin wieder so in einem kaputten Modus gerade, mein Hirn ist total... Naja, also mit allen Defiziten, die die Plattform so hat, ist es trotzdem sehr angenehm.
Ja, also man könnte noch ins Detail gehen bei tausend Dingen, aber ich denke, so die groben Dinge sind gefallen und ja, es ist vom Programmierperspektive genauso wie auf Mac eine wahnsinnig schöne Plattform, man kriegt Schnellzeug, Schnellzeug gebacken, Schnellzeug hinprogrammiert, ich meine, es ist ja da im Wesentlichen auch das Gleiche, von der Idee her nur halt noch mal die Dinge, die neu gemacht wurden, wirklich noch mal optimiert, also wirklich noch mal so, da gibt es noch Potenzial nach oben, also ich kann mich nur auf die nächsten Mac OS X Versionen freuen, wo die Entwickler auch diese Ebenen alle wieder zurückbekommen.
Und man kann halt auch in kleinen Gruppen viel reisen, das ist sowohl der Mac als auch das iPhone noch, eigentlich noch mehr, so richtig.
So wie ihr das macht, zu zweit, am Haken, am iPhone und am Mac, als die Coding-Monkeys. Und ja, ich würde sagen, ich ziehe jetzt hier mal die Reißleine und lasse den Podcast langsam den Boden segeln.
Im Rettungsschirm.
Genau, bevor wir uns noch verletzen und auf dem harten Boden der Themenwelt aufschlagen. Oh Gott, jetzt wird es ein bisschen zu lyrisch. Ich sage Dankeschön, Dominik und Martin, für die Ausführung. Das war es, Ausgabe Nummer 101 vom Chaosradio Express. Es geht bald munter weiter. Dann kommt eine kleine Weihnachtspause und dann geht es noch munterer weiter. Ich mache jetzt hier auch schon Aktivgebrauch von meiner durch die Spenden eingetriebenen Bahncard, die mich hoffentlich noch ein paar andere interessante Winkel der Bundesrepublik bringt. Vor allem Winkel, die ich noch nicht gesehen habe. Aber ich komme sicherlich auch mal wieder in München vorbei. Und ja, das war es. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank. Wir sagen Tschüss. Und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.